welcome to this new series by
sapiens institute this new series is
going to focus on
scientific errors or the supposed
scientific errors narrative which is
propounded
by some of the anti-muslim apologists
this series deals with the most
notable contentions as per
mentions of these particular contentions
on different anti-islamic websites and
publications
this is brought to you by sapiens
institute
an institute which focuses on two
primary things
number one is to further the cause of
islam to make
rational arguments for islam and that
ranges from making arguments from god's
existence
to the oneness of god all the way
through to the revelation of the prophet
muhammad
and the proof of his prophethood
the second objective is that sapiens
institutes deals with the most
contentious and controversial objections
against islam
and this is where this series fits
into the scheme of work if you like of
what we do
we have decided to spend some months
actually collating data and using
the interdisciplinary approach where we
consult with scientists with theologians
with scholars of different backgrounds
within the islamic tradition
and of course with philosophers of
science
to come to conclusions about the extent
to which there is in fact a conflict a
supposed conflict
between what is observably uh
observable to us empirically let's say
and the quranic text this of course
requires
knowledge in many different areas and
i would like to thank all of those who
contributed to this series
before i begin now
this video comprises of the as i've
mentioned
most common contentions you may
see the most common contentions in the
description box below
because you might not need answers to
all of them so you might have
a particular contention that you would
like answered
rather than all of them and so you can
go to the description box which will act
like a contents page
and you can click on the particular
objection that you would like
to be answered in this way
this will act like a virtual web
database
on the matter of supposed scientific
discrepancies in the quran
now here's the thing before we begin
it's very important
that we say from the outset
that whatever school of philosophical
thought you take on the philosophy of
science whether you are a realist or an
anti-realist
you must you must realize that even the
best
scientific theories with the best kind
of predictive power
are are susceptible to change
this is the dynamism and the transient
nature of the scientific method
if it were not so then falsification
would not be
something which could happen so science
is not a set of eternal truths
and incorrigible facts
to the contrary science is transient and
dynamic
to the contrary science can change even
that which is known to us a scientific
fact
can in fact change as we know through
the great works of thomas kuhn
where he refers to these as scientific
revolutions
not just scientific facts change but the
entire paradigm
where in which science operates may
undergo
what is referred to as scientific
revolution this has happened many times
in history and so it's important from
the outset
not to have an expectation
that there must be a perfect correlation
between
today's science of 2021 for example
and every single verse of the quran and
every single hadith that there is that
is authentic
this is not a reasonable expectation not
least because
the scientific method itself is in flux
however having said this anything which
is
observably real and true
and has very high epistemic weight from
an empirical perspective
we would say that truth cannot
contradict the quranic
narrative and so bearing all of these
things in mind
it's important to approach the topic of
science in the quran
with care and nuance and sophistication
i hope this series is something which
you can benefit from
it is certainly something which we have
put a lot of time in
a lot of effort in and we will be doing
this
with major themes of
narratives against islam from morality
all the way through to arguments as
we've said
of god's existence and hopefully you can
benefit
and share this video to all those who
you think will benefit
today inshallah we're going to be
dealing with a hadith
which references adam alaihissalam a
prophet of islam
as being 60 cubits tall which is like 27
meters
and they say this is unbelievable and
impossible but before we get to this
hadith
let's talk about the islamic stance on
the theory of evolution generally
speaking talking about the
theory of evolution muslims don't have
an issue or shouldn't really have an
issue with
speciation adaptation or even evolution
of animals because we believe
that there's nothing explicit in the
quran one way the other and actually
done a podcast
with abdullah is
a prominent figure in saudi arabia who
researches these matters and well
published in this field
and were in my discussion with him this
was his opinion
so which is quite frankly like 99.9
percent if we look at it from a mass
perspective
really 99.9 of the theory the
uh the issue we have um we take
issue with or the point of evolution of
slither of which really diametrically
opposes some of the islamic narratives
is
human evolution now obviously we have a
narrative we have a narrative in islam
which is that the adam ali was created
directly or this prophet adam was
created directly by allah
by god almighty and there are many
things which differentiate human beings
from the rest of the animal kingdom
morality the the
the ability to question why you know um
this is many different in language
civilization and so on and so forth
and it couldn't have been the case we
would argue that
we can actually in any way be equated
to the rest of the animal kingdom and
there's something special about human
beings
in the quran that he has dignified the
children of adam so we we don't
necessarily agree or disagree we can
remain agnostic as to
uh you know darwinian evolution with
other animals but as it relates to
the human being there is something
special about the human being
and that is why allah created human
being directly
and in this hadith there's indication
that he created adam
is 60 cubits tall now the question is
this
seems unscientific on many grounds and
i'll tell you what on three
major grounds number one is biological
number two is archaeological
and or paleontological you could say as
well from a fossil record perspective
and number three uh looking at the kind
of
disparity in sizes if we do assume that
there was a human being of
such great magnitude in terms of size
how can we explain the fact
that human beings are like uh give or
take you know six foot tall give or take
you know
half a meter or whatever it may be or
more right but
how can you explain this huge disparity
in the fact that you're saying that you
believe in adam who's 27 meters tall and
and a human being now which is you know
typically anything between
five foot five to six foot five and
obviously there are extremities on
on both sides of that equation as more
people are taller than six or five like
myself
and people are shorter than five foot
five like many many people
so here there's two parts of the hadith
which we need to pay attention to
which is the first part of the hadith it
talks about that allah created
them 60 cubits
tall and in terms of hadith
there are some narrations which don't
mention this 60 qubits
and that the the there are some
narrations that do mention the 60 qubits
but we don't say that just because there
are some narrations that don't mention
the 60 qubits
that the narrations that do mention
these qubits are erroneous
that makes no sense actually uh this
this doesn't and some people have
attempted to argue
that this means that this should be a
disbanded known that doesn't mean that's
not how the hadith science works
so that's the first thing other people
say the second part of the hadith which
talks about
the creation is um is is becoming
smaller and smaller until now
they found it problematic because even
himself he mentions
how could it be the case that this is
happening
right that and we can see adam tamud's
uh kind of
indwellings the the archaeological
remnants of their indwellings and we can
see that their houses and that
you know the doors and so on were not so
tall and he assumed
and without by the way nas and evidence
that
uh were closer to adam than they were to
us human beings
and obviously the only real evidence we
have anything between
and adam alaihissalam is
there's no evidence i mean there's only
uh israelite or kind of biblical
narrations
so potentially he was using those to
kind of raise his eyebrow but he did not
say this
or defective as many believe that he did
now having oh because of nast reasons or
content reasons
going our forward to answering the
contentions there are
variations of this hadith which referred
to fist sama
okay that this was in the heaven not
heaven
as in jannah but now obviously if you
look at the quranic cosmology
heaven is above okay because obviously
we know that the prophet was taken there
in this
so it could be the case that this height
and this
mega size of 27 meters is specific to
jannah
and there's nothing wrong linguistically
in believing that because obviously we
believe that adam ali
salaam he started his journey yes in
heaven i mean we have a whole narrative
where he was in a completely different
place
and then allah he sent him down to the
earth he sent him down
to the earth yes he's created from the
elements of the earth but he was
in many ways an extraterrestrial because
he came from a completely different
dimension
and he came to this earth now in that
transition period could he have shrunk
could allah have made him smaller that's
also a possibility we're not
disregarding that as a possibility but
there's no evidence of that from the
quran
sunnah so we can't say that that is what
happened and what we will say is this
let's assume that allah he brought adam
down
he was 60 cubits either in heaven and
on earth or in heaven or on the earth
but let's just assume that he was a
60 cubits in heaven and on the earth so
when he came down
he was also 27 27 meters which by the
way now we're starting to make
assumptions which we don't
necessarily need to be i'd need to make
we can say no this
he was like that high in heaven and when
he came on the earth he
became normal height that that's
something you can assume from the
from the source but let's not assume
that
let's say he was 27 meters on the earth
what's the problem
what's the problem the problem are three
different things now number one biology
if we use the human anatomy that we have
today as the reference point
if if the if the human anatomy today is
the reference point
how could it be that something that tall
or human being that tall
the bone structure can maintain that
kind of size right because it will
collapse because of the weight
of the human being well this is a
fallacy because we're not starting with
the human being today as the reference
point we're starting with
why would you start with today's human
being as a reference point the reference
point
is that 27 meter human being that we're
talking about
that's the reference point so if someone
says well we know that if we keep
doubling sizes
as i've even heard some some muslims try
and say keep doubling sizes and height
then the height will be so at all and
then the weight will be so much and then
the
bones will not be able to handle that
density of the bones will not be able to
handle that
you're using your reference point uh
as the human anatomy of today and then
doing chaos backwards
which is a class malfurion if you like
or a false type of analogy
it's a different kind it's false kind of
analogy so that's the first problem you
could say or
it's inconceivable that human anatomy
can can handle that size
well it's only inconceivable on the
basis of
analyzing today's human activity that's
the first thing the second thing we may
say
is someone could say well um we talked
about the biological problems
fossilization how comes there is no
fossil record
of such a huge human the national
science foundation
says that 99.9
99.9 oh my
99.9 percent of species have not
undergone
fossilization so fossilization you
expect
to find one specimen
of a fossil of a human that we don't
know tens or hundred thousand
whatever is years that he existed before
no way
and this is like finding a needle in the
haystack it's ridiculous
to expect to find fossils like this is
absolutely absurd
it's such a redundant redundant
interrogation so that that one would be
put to the side
the third now interrogation is well
how can we conceive of such a disparity
between
uh humans within this or any kind of
animal within the same species like this
let's say we don't accept that we don't
accept that you can have a 27
meter human being and then you can have
a six foot human being
and that disparity existed and they say
humans have been around for 350 000
years which is by the way estimates we
don't have to go with because they keep
changing those quite frankly
but let's just assume for the sake of
argument are you saying to me it's my
response
that you have there's no species within
the species that
exhibit this decrease in size
this dramatic exponential decrease in
size because i can give you an example
of the dwarf elephants
which the general proceedings national
academy of science
shows the dwarf elephants were 220
pounds
they they went down in 800 000 years
according to
the journal in 800 000 years they went
down
100 times in size so they were they were
100 times bigger than they were they
became dwarf elephants
220 pounds 100 kilos which would mean
that i'm bigger than those elephants me
personally the one who's talking to you
on the imagine an elephant
that i can pick up or that you can pick
up and that would be heavier to pick me
up
than an elephant i mean this is just to
give you some kind of visuals here
so if you can believe
in an elephant that is
that size because you're looking at the
fossil record and you're
making your uh evolutionarily uh
evolution
uh inferences then why can you not
believe in
a human being that's much bigger there's
just one of many examples
but within a very short time span in
evolutionary terms
so why could not that happen to the
human
i mean if you really want to believe it
on your paradigm why could not that
happen to the human being
so it's okay when you say these things
but it's not okay when you say these
things you make a mockery of the hadith
but the hadith makes the mockery out of
you because this is actually what you
believe in as well
and hopefully that answers the question
today insha'allah we're going to be
discussing
a particular verse and actually there's
more than one of them
in the quran which make these kinds of
references but we'll focus on one
because
the same thing that can be said of this
verse can be said of all of the other
ones which have similar phraseologies
and this is a verse in chapter number 55
of the quran verses 19 to 21.
says
that he let free this the two seas of
water and he put between them a barrier
that he cannot
transgress between now i recently saw
and i saw this before
long time ago a video of richard dawkins
richard dawkins actually
going to a school with some muslim
students some young students and this is
a common tactic
you go for the weak ones the untrained
ones uh
you know the the students that they're
not theologians they're not learned
they're still actually even
haven't finished their gcses and this is
the kind of you know
engagements that richard dawkins and the
rest of the new atheist movement
are used to doing with the muslims you
get some weak one
and you try and brainwash them uh into
your world view
and he was you know talking um
to these little girls or these
young girls and he was trying to
persuade them that
really he was that the quran was wrong
he wasn't saying
in any explicit type of way but he was
being very pedantic maybe we can get
a clip of this video and see what he has
what he's doing here
we learn about science and the quran by
the end of the day we all came to one
conclusion
that the quran is evidence of science
what science has proved to be um just
recently it's already proved in the
quran 1400 years ago when it was written
but that doesn't include evolution
apparently
so what does it include it includes
stuff like the shape of the earth
um about the um the mountains how they
secure the earth
and how um in the sea the two waters
they don't mix the salty water
and the drinking water so it's um pure
for us to drink
they don't mix but they pass through
each other
salty water and fresh water don't mix in
the sea
no it's like um the natural barrier
i was shocked that re elbows out science
like this
as you saw this man was badgering the
kids um
he doesn't want to go to train
theologians or muslim theologians or
public figures or whatever it may be
he's going for the children
and really he's arguing that this is
false in the quran if the idea is that
you have these
uh the sweet water the fresh water and
the salty water
that there is a barrier between that
he's no such barrier exists he said you
can go to the kitchen
yes you can put the sweet you can put
the you know these two waters together
and mix them and disprove the quran
you know this is such a weak and lazy
approach don't you want to research what
this verse is talking about in the first
place
because if you just went to even an
english translation of the exegesis of
such verses
you don't realize that the prominent or
the most popular
exegetical opinion on this was that the
barrier in question were the land masses
that were separating seas from rivers
for example the arabian peninsula
for example other land masses that
separate these things
so on the one side of this land mass you
have maybe a cna other
side you have a river and within the
land
you have a river flowing this is what is
being referred to here
that god in his uh greatness is able to
allow such different types of waters to
exist
within uh the sphere of the earth and
this is
uh what's wrong with that was what's so
unscientific about that
why are you so lazy as to not go to a
tafsir in english and check out that
that was
the primary exegetical
method of understanding this verse you
see
and this is what happens when you don't
do your research
yes there are some scholars who say it's
an invisible barrier and this has
now gone to the scientific miracles
narrative and so on
but we're not even going to go there
some say it's talking about uh
estuaries and others says this and it's
talking about
i'm not going there this is enough for
me to say
that your shenanigans has been exposed
that you didn't even make an attempt
you didn't even make an attempt to try
and understand the verse
and read up some opinions on it
today inshallah we're going to be
talking about a contention which is
really a feeble and weak
intention contention sorry which
like many of those is really lazy
academics at its best it's the
contention that says
that the quran mentions sperm
but it does not mention ovum and
therefore the
author authorship of the quran was
unaware
that sachin ovum existed in the first
place
well actually the quran doesn't mention
spermatozoa the word nutha
which is sometimes translated as sperm
drop
if you look at any of the ancient kind
of linguistic
dictionaries it simply means
or a minute quantity of liquid or fluid
that's what it means now some
translators have translated this to mean
spermatozoa
or not even that sperm drop or something
like this
but that is us putting our own kind of
21st century glasses on
and imposing it on the quran the quran
even now the arabs when they're talking
about when they write in their
kind of scientific textbooks about uh
sperm they call it
menowi okay it's basically the animal
which
sperm animal you know this is how they
translate it because the word nutha
is not specific enough to that very you
know
sperm that we see in diagrams i'm sure
you've seen
in pictures and so on in films or
whatever it may be so the quran doesn't
mention
that nor does it mention uh the egg it
doesn't mention the egg
and it's because no one would understand
this i mean think about the quran is
trying to
reach out to a 7th century 8th century
9th century audience not just a 21st
century audience
imagine if telling the end user here
that inside of the sperm that comes out
or you emit as a man
there is actually animals in there all
the people would be like
what was this talking about i mean think
about that the quran uses phraseology
which is appropriate for all peoples in
all times
it uses perfect phraseology which we
as for example 21st century end users of
the quranic discourse can understand
you know with with for example the
biological and embryological
understanding of today
but also that it couldn't alienate the
7th or 8th century or 9th century
10th century people up until the age
when the microscope was developed
this is uh foolishness at its core
really this assumption
so yes it doesn't doesn't mention the
sperm in that sense it doesn't mention
the ovum in that sense
but the indications to be quite honest
with you
are all there that show that the
authorship of quran
of the quran or the author of the quran
was
acutely aware
like for example
says
we have created the human being from a
mixture
of fluids and we have made him seeing
and hearing
now what is this mixture almost
everybody agrees it's talking
about the the male and female
fluids combining now what fluids are we
talking about the entirety of it because
we know it only requires one cell from
each
and this is also indicated in the hadith
of the prophet muhammad
it says
that the born child is not from the
entirety of the fluid so subhanallah
even this so you have this nu farm
you have this mixture between the male
and female fluids
which we know uh it happens
in fertilization but it's only a part of
this
entirety of thing which creates the
fertilization and what's fascinating is
that the sperm
and the ovum and the egg are all
contained within a fluid
and this is uh beautifully elaborated
with the one who says
i've been given the brief and decisive
speech who's the prophet muhammad who
said
that it's not from the entirety of this
liquid but it's actually
from a part of it so this it seems to me
that is the author of the quran and
the the the sunnah as well
was aware was aware of these
the mind you say related to these things
and i think this is really a shot in the
foot for those
detractors because the more we look at
your evidences with the more we realize
the beauty and the precision of the
quranic
discourse
today we're going to be speaking about a
very
fruitless and frivolous and capricious
claim
a weak claim a ridiculous contention
of the highest order really a claim that
says that
the quran says in chapter number 51
verse number 49 that everything was
created in pairs
and we know of such a thing as a sexual
reproduction
and therefore this is false so
i don't know whether to stop roll my
eyes
or even try and dignify this uh thing
with the
with the response but maybe i should for
the
for the satisfaction of those who are a
little bit curious
really and truly we've said this more
than once the word kul
does not necessarily mean every single
thing
with the exclusion of nothing in the
genus this is something which we know
from the usage of the word kul which is
also used in the quran
that it destroys there's a wind that
destroys everything
with the command of its lord so
they came to be not seen except for
their indwellings
and of course this does not mean that
this wind
that allah is talking about
is a wind that destroyed everything
including animals and the
earth and the cosmos even though
there's the exception there illa
masakinuhum
except for their indwellings it doesn't
mean everything was destroyed except for
the indwelling so the
kul here is not intended by any means
or any stretch of the imagination
to mean every single thing
on the face of the earth let alone the
entire
existence or entire universe this is
impossible
to extrapolate from this verse and that
is why many of the scholars have
actually
written books and criticism about this
word kul
because many people that employ
literalistic understandings
of the arabic language do not understand
these kinds of usages so sulti
wrote a book
or the word kul and what it implies or
what its
evidences or shows now is it talking
about animals
uh it doesn't say animals in this verse
but it doesn't mean just animals because
if you look at some of the
exegesis of the past even of
uh great uh scholars like hassan basri
and others
and even if you look at what he says
they don't restrict this
to just meaning male and female for
example they say
azoge is anything and it's opposite so
for example if you have
night then the opposite will be the day
if you have heaven the opposite will be
the
earth for example you know from our
perspective before someone jumps and
says no this is
just calm down we're talking about the
anthropocentric perspective otherwise
it's all meaningless we're nothing
in the universe anyway so here again
this is a flatly weak and false
contention pouring into the quran what
they wish
was in there and is not in there so
simply to answer this question
the word cool doesn't mean every single
thing and it's not restricted
to male and female uh distinctions
it could be anything and it's opposite
quite frankly
and this is facilitated in the language
and understood by the classical
executives of the time
and i hope this answers the question
assalamu alaikum mohammed sallallahu
africa
today inshallah we're going to be
tackling and dealing with a
contention a misconception a misnomer
really
uh that some of the anti-islamic
apologists use in order to further their
case
and this is a very common one that's
been circulating maybe the internet for
some time
and really it's a contention that says
that the quran gets it wrong when it
says that the bones form before
flesh when in suratul
the um chapter 22 in chapter 23
respectively of the quran
they detail the stages of umbrella
embryological development or embryonic
development
when these two surahs do so the mistake
they say in the
the chronology is that the bones are
mentioned before
the flesh
and they say this is something which is
problematic now
first of all let's take a look at what
the the latest cutting edge
uh you know kind of research is saying
on this i'm going to read this from
directly because this is not my area of
specialism so i'm just going to be
doing this diana or using this book
which is the fundamentals of human
embryology by john allen and
beverly cramer to inform the discussion
today let's start off with what they say
about the development of lim lim
musculature it says for many years and
it's very interesting because
science as we always say is a transient
and dynamic and developing
thing and so when maybe 20 or 30 years
ago they were using these kinds of
interrogations against the quran the
fact that
science has developed okay actually
shows us
that we have to be a bit careful making
uh judgments about the quran using
science
either positively or negatively because
listen to what they say
she says or he says because we don't
know who's writing it here
for many years it was believed that limb
muscles differentiated in situ
from lim mesench mesenchyme
it is now known that myogenic cells
invade the limb buds from the somites at
the roots of the butt however it seems
that tendons and other connective
tissue elements of the muscles are
formed in situ
from the limb bud uh mesenchyme now the
mesenchyme is not yet
actualized or it's not really developed
into one of the
three main types of cell which would
either form a skin bone or muscle
but this the point of importance here is
is this particular thing
and this is very important here soon
after the cartilaginous models of the
bones have been established the myogenic
cells
which have now become myoblasts
aggregate to form
muscle masses on the ventral and dorsal
aspects of the limbs
these muscle masses in the relevant
compartments
form the flexors and extenders of the
joints rotator muscles are also formed
so that flexes and pronators
are related and extend extensors and
supinators are related now basically in
lay language which people like me are
more need of than i'm pretty sure are
informed and educated audiences
what we're talking about when they say
myoblast sorry myogenic cells so the
myogenic cells would eventually become
muscle tissue okay so what is being said
here is that you've got these
cartilaginous models right
and the cartilaginous models would
eventually become ossified through a
process of
osteogenesis or ossification which
actually continues until puberty and
this
basically forms the bone it becomes
ossified so these cartilaginous
zones basically you have these myogenic
cells coming now
forming over the cartilaginous zones now
what are the carcinogenous
zones or models they basically form what
would then
become muscles after the process of
sorry bones after the process of
ossification
now the question is can cartilage in the
arabic language
be used to describe bones or
our bone a type of sorry is cartilage a
type of bone in the arabic language
because if it is then the whole issue
from a scientific perspective
has become becomes an honesty straight
away and the answer is yes
the answer is the word roof in the
arabic language which means cartilage
the word roof in the arabic language
which means cartilage according to
pharus abadi in his book
in his dictionary and of course which is
one of the
premier gold standard you know reference
points as a from a dictionary
perspective
on the arabic language and when they
describe
roof it says you know album legend or
something like this or basically
it's his bone which is very smooth in
other words cartilage
is a type of bone in the arabic language
so could it be the case could it be the
case
that this verse is talking about this
process
of the myogenic cells migrating uh to
the cartilaginous models
yes it could very well be and if it is
the entire contention is completely
uh solved but of course does it mean
does it have to say faka sauna
or chronology or sequentialism the
answer is not really
it could be conceived that the fair hair
is not necessarily chronological
and we can bring evidences all over the
quran and sunnah
to evidence's case but suffice it for me
to say
that that is not necessary at this
juncture since the whole issue has
become
a non-issue according to the current
scientific information that we have
but no definitely it could be that
the fair is not the could be and also
you have to remember one other thing
that it says
it says we have clothed the ivan with
meat or with flesh it doesn't say that
we have
yes created the flesh in other words
it may be the case it may be the case
that the meat also the flesh or whatever
you want to call it
that it was already there but it was
rearranged because el
kiso is different from hulk so clothing
something is different from it
being created especially from
non-emergent properties
in other words coming from non-emergence
there's a difference between those two
things
and in fact albedavis has something very
interesting in history who is an early
professor he talks about the stage which
is referred to in suratul
he talks about when it's formed and from
the mudra which is
another really really interesting
description because mudra
is literally means something which is
chewed a chewed-like flesh
or chewed-like thing and this is what
the dictionaries all the dictionaries
will say to the arabic dictionaries so
mudra really
mudra really could be very well
corresponding with
what is referred to today in the
embryology as someone saw massage
somatogenesis the soul mites being
formed on the
uh on the embryo and the fact that
could be talking about the cells
migrating in different ways and
operating or operationalizing and
functioning in different ways
this is very possible but it's suffice
it for me to say once again
that if we accept the premise
that the cartilaginous models or zones
which
have not been fully ossified and will
not be fully ossified by the way
because this is the assumption of the uh
the attack
are sufficient to be renamed as the
quran
then according to the latest science
that we have this becomes a non-issue
straight away and hopefully that answers
the question with salaam alaikum
today insha'allah we're going to be
talking about one of the most spurious
and species claims that i've actually
ever seen against islam
that it beggars belief that people are
actually using this as an argument
against islam
it's such a blow to the credibility of
those individuals
that they are making arguments so
desperate and so pathetic as this what
is the argument that we're talking about
so this is one of the arguments they say
that the quran says that there's
feminist as wedge that there are eight
types of as wedge or
pairs and with that it's talking about
the anaheim
and that there are four types of an am
is loosely translated as cattle
and the quran says you know
that from the from the sheep there are
two pairs and from the mass the goats
there are two pairs
and from the bakari's name from the cows
there are two pairs
and from the ibalith name and from the
camel zero two pairs and they say look
this is from what i've understood from
their contention because it's so
pathetic that it actually beggars once
again believe
if you take for example the collins
dictionary definition of the word cattle
what i've seen is that it says for
example boved mammals
of the tribe of uh bovines especially
those of genus
boss and then you go to bovin uh bovid
and potentially this is what they're
referring to here that can relate to
a family of hollow-horned mammals
including sheeps goats cattle antelopes
and buffalo
so my understanding of their contention
is that they're saying that the word an
am
is rich or cattle loosely defined or
translated
is limited in the chronic paradigm where
it should be more
expansive now the question is this why
should we accept
this definition if this is the
definition you want us to accept
this is clearly a case of the fallacy of
equivocation
you're you're forcing one language
into another language paradigm this is
ridiculous behavior
and in fact it actually assures me that
you people anti-islamic apologists
have no understanding at all of the
arabic language and that
you're relying heavily if not entirely
on translations
because if you just looked at tafsir
tabari of chapter number 16
verse number 5 and he mentions what the
word and means he mentions that it means
those four things the word anam itself
means those four things the sheep
and goats and cows and
camels you could do better than this
this is embarrassing
wassalamualaikum
today inshallah we're going to be
talking about a verse which is
uh littered all over these kind of
anti-islamic websites
this is in chapter 86 verse number 7
he says
human being see where he has been uh
from what he has been created he has
been created from a secreted or gushing
fluid
that comes from all that he comes from
and we'll talk about the differences in
translation
between the backbone and the ribs and
obviously here survive is translated in
more than one way and we'll come to this
the contention is that this is actually
unscientific because we know that
spermiogenesis
uh happens in the testicles and
it doesn't happen between the backbones
in the ribs for example
and the assumption obviously is that
what is being referred to
in the verse when it says is sperm
and therefore this verse is out of line
with observable reality
and it's a proof against islam this is
the this is the contention
so let's deal with one thing at a time
first and foremost does the word
what does the words actually mean
so there are three opinions which are
represented in the classical literature
and the dictionaries either we're
talking about the backbone and the ribs
of the man
all we're talking about the backbones of
the ribs and the
backbones of the man and the ribs of the
woman
all we're talking about the backbone and
the ribs of the woman
and we're not talking about the secreted
uh liquid or the secreted fluids
but instead we're talking about the
insane
the human being himself because that
verse says
insane let the human being see from
which
or from that which has been created
has been created from a gushing of
secreted fluid
which comes from between the backbone
and the ribs
now could it mean that the human being
insane let the human being see which
where he's being created from
holy coming
so the the opinion that says the
classical apologetical approach or
apologetics approach
for those who take the view that is
talking about mumbai or
the backbone and the ribs of the man is
to say well actually this is saying
it's saying secreted fluid is talking
about gushing fluid
and we know that yes spermiogenesis
happens in the testes but it goes up the
epididymis
and actually there is something called
seminal vesicle and
it collects seminal fluids from there
and it comes back down the urethra and
then when ejaculation happens
what then takes place is obviously the
emission
happens and so the the seminal fluids
right the seminal fluids are collected
from either the seminal vesicles and all
the prostate that's
opinion one so they say that being
sullivan
is anything above the coccyx and what's
parallel to it because
the coccyx or algebra then up in the
arabic language is where the
backbone ends venus would be the
between the the backbone and the ribs so
that the backbone
ends at the algebra venab or the coccyx
so every part of the intersection there
and that means to say from a human
reproductive perspective that anything
which is above the penis
because the penis is parallel to from an
anatomical perspective to the coccyx
and we know that the seminal vesicles
and
uh we know that also the prostate is
above the penis
and so they say this is uh in fact most
bukwa
in his famously said this is a
scientific miracle of the quran but
we're not going down that route
we're just saying this is one apologetic
approach of answering the question
and it may be satisfactory to some it
may not be satisfactory to others
and the language actually is
facilitative of that
now the second approach where we say
that it's talking about the backbone of
the man
and the ribs of the woman they say this
is talking about oogenesis
because uh genesis happens in the
ovaries of the woman
and uh this is where the eggs are
basically being formed
and so that happens above the once again
the vagina which is parallel to the
coccyx
and so the same kind of argument is made
and they say so this
is talking about the fluids because
there's a fluid that carries
either the egg or the sperm for both man
and woman and so they say this is not
talking about because the arabic word
not far is not used here no
not is categorized
as a minute quantity of liquid
but the the phraseology used here is
manda a gushing secretive fluid
so the someone would notice the
differentiation
between the two kinds of uh words that
are used that's the first thing that
that is said so yes this is one approach
the other approach but one other
approach which has not been highlighted
as much which also has classical
precedent
and is mentioned uh by ibm
in his tafsir and also by al qurtoby in
his as one of the
one of two main opinions that he
mentions in this verse
is that this is not talking about the
secreted fluid at all let's talking
about
what is understood in the language here
in the subtext
is
that the human being is comes from vain
and this is talking about pregnancy and
birth and this would be
completely uncontroversial because
obviously the baby is in the
intersection between the backbone and
the ribs of the woman
and so these are three very legitimate
ways to to answer the question
and three very acceptable things no one
can really especially with the third
opinion now
i see no way i see
no way anyone can say this against
observable reality
and therefore to try and use this verse
to indicate that
only sperm which by the way that the
word sperm is not mentioned in the
scientific senses in the quran the
menowi which the arabs
have now invented and put into
biological textbooks is
is created between the backbones and the
ribs this is ignorance
and it's not a comprehensive
understanding of the quranic discourse
today inshallah we're going to be
refuting debunking computing
and rejecting a claim that is made by
the anti-muslim
or anti-islamic apologists which is
actually quite a weak
weaker than spiders web type of claim
which is they say that the sky
or the heaven or the universe is
presented
in the islamic cosmology in the quran in
particular
as a solid object and they to in order
to kind of strengthen their
case refer to two different verses of
the quran
one that is mentioned in chapter number
22 verse number 65
where allah subhanahu ta'ala says that
he holds a she holds the heavens and the
earth
sorry
that he holds the heaven that it falls
on the earth and they say look at this
in order for that to be the case that
the you know the heaven has to be
a solid object and therefore the
presentation of the quran is that the
heaven
is a solid object and the other verse
that they mentioned is in chapter number
two
and chapter number 35 verse number 41
where allah says uh that he
yumsik
that he holds the heavens and the earth
that they would fall out of their place
or they would come out of their place or
that they would be moved out of their
place
from from the words like zoell something
to be moved out of his place or to move
move away in general so these are the
two
verses that they do is the shad with or
they try and evidence
to suggest that the quran's picture the
cosmological picture
is one which is uh that the heaven or
the universe is a solid object
now this is uh false for two reasons and
the second of which i think really is an
undercutter by the way
um so i don't want to hear this again i
mean only an embarrassed person after
hearing the second of my sec of two or
three points i'm gonna make
would dare to challenge this point it's
just so embarrassing
to be honest the first point is this
sometimes allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
when he refers to something as a whole
he can refer to a part
meaning the whole and this is part of
the kind of phraseological
myriological um terminological
usages of the quran so myriology is the
parts of whole and
po holes and parts allah for example in
the quran says
that they put their fingers in their is
now really did they put their entire
look at the size of the finger
you put the entire uk it's impossible
really to put the entire finger in the
ear
so what is being intended here is that
banan the
the enamel the enamel the the finger tip
and you put it in the air
but here you see the fingertip which
i'll refer to in arabic is animal
are not this is he didn't say that he
said they put their asa
even though the enamel the fingertip is
that which is there likewise now with
this
when allah says it doesn't necessarily
have to mean
everything in the uh heaven it could
mean
he says in his tafsir that is referring
to certain things like meteor
is referring to snow which comes from
above and below it's referring to
rain it's referring to this referring to
that all of these things that are
above us
from our anthropological
phenomenological perspective
fall on us yes what's the problem and
this is a linguistically acceptable for
the reasons aforementioned
understanding of the verse but let's
move a little bit further
if really and this is the undercutter
here wait for it wait for it
if really the quran's picture of the
heaven the sama
is that of a solid object my question to
you is this
how could the prophet muhammad do is
through a solid object
see how embarrassing that must i mean as
i say this to you now
how embarrassed do you feel as the
anti-islamic apologist
very embarrassing isn't it and the quran
even says
it's mentioned in chapter number six you
know verse 125
he even says he's talking about
as if he is ascending in the heaven
how is this conceivable if the sort of
the heaven
is a solid object i rest my case ladies
and gentlemen well i
was there i rest my case yanny sorry to
say this should never be heard again now
it's so embarrassing
they are saying that the quran says that
the heaven is a solid object
when one of the most uh central things
in the prophet seerah
biography is that he done israel
and he done israel he went up the heaven
how can you go up to heaven when it's a
solid object come on please
really really these people do not employ
critical reasoning when they're dealing
with the quran now
another ishq that somewhat problematized
thing that someone can say is that how
come
now if we take on face value and we're
not saying it's a part of the heaven
that falls
can we still understand it to mean that
the heaven is some kind of the fabric of
space
is going to implode upon itself it's
going to create a black hole or
something like that
and that it would appear to us as if
it's falling if that is the case
god knows best the k fear or the howness
of how such
um how such a thing would take place and
how it would look from our perspective
if it was in this for example initial
phases or
if it was in this end phases is
something we cannot speculate on
but we should remember that allah when
he's speaking to the human being
he is speaking to him in his own
anthropoce
anthropocentric phenomenological
perspective and that means
from his his perspectival is from his
perspective
and i i rest my case i don't think
there's anything more to be said about
this was today insha'allah we're going
to be talking about a hadith
which is uh all over the anti-islamic
apologetics type websites and it's in
their publications and their videos
online
which is a hadith which says that the
prophet muhammad
said
that whoever wakes up and consumes seven
dates of ajwa kind
that poison will not afflict him and
sehar which is magic
will not afflict him and they say this
is an unscientific type of hadith
because they say how could it be the
case when the chemical
agents or properties within the within
the dates there's nothing within them
that would indicate to us from a
scientific perspective
that they could be um immunizing to
things
uh as as chemically destructive as
uh poison so why how can you understand
this hadith and this doesn't this had
these fly in the face
of 21st century scientific discovery now
first in order to answer this question
let's take a look at what some of the
commentators of this hadith of our time
have mentioned so for example
who is a scholar of the 4th century dai
388
ah he says actually it's not because of
a specific property within the dates
he says this there's nothing within the
date that
actually has that immunizing capacity it
says
it's not because of a specific
characteristic
attribute today where innama is because
of the dawah of the prophet muhammad
the blessings of the tao of the prophet
muhammad and many of the scholars
have uh have looked at this hadith in
this kind of way ibn
said no it's for a special time in a
special place and it's not applicable to
us
can only be seen to be applicable to us
if it goes through the experimental
method and succeeds in the sense that
we can actually prove that the dates
are in fact in line immunizing to poison
and this shows us that the the the
commentators of hadith had a very sober
approach
to science and hadith and science and
quran
they understood that sometimes these are
two separate areas
of uh jurisdiction if you like and
sometimes they have an overlap
now before we continue with this hadith
the
opinion of which says it's not a
specific property
in the date seems to be well represented
if we look at other hadith because
there's another hadith
which the prophet muhammad he told us in
the what you call the
evening supplications which we should
all be making by the way
beautiful supplications we should be
making in the morning and the evening
that will cause protection for us and so
on one of these words of protection
is uh it is
that i seek refuge with the perfect
words of god from the evil from which
she created
and the prophet muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam he said about this
he said whoever says this
he said that whoever says this nothing
will afflict him
or no harm will afflict him now wait a
minute if
the day hadith was intended to be an
immunization
a physical or chemical immunization
then how comes we find similar or even
more generic
even more generic types of terminology
used in other hadith
if you think about this this cannot mean
it's a physical thing because this is a
supplication
which doesn't necessitate any
consumption of anything physical
at all so this hadith of the dates
from that perspective it follows that it
wouldn't be because of the
properties of the date but it's because
of
the alibaba that all the worship of
doing
eating seven dates so it's a worship
just like drinking zamzam water as a
is a worship just like doing aldo is a
worship just like making dua is a
worship
and yes we believe if you do that
particular worship
allah will protect you yes from sum
from poison and yes from yes he will
unless there is a man and the moana or
the preventers
can be many like for example to give you
an example
there is a hadith which says that if you
make dua
if you supplicate to god but then your
actions
your income and your consumption
is all haram it's all impermissible
then how can it be that your
supplication will be
accepted even though the quran says
that if my slave asks me about me then
say i am near
then i am there i answer the call
of the caller when he calls so allah is
telling us he's going to answer
but in other parts of the sunnah in the
quran he indicates to us
that actually there are moana to dua
which are for example if you have haram
income if you have haram if you commit
sins and so on and so forth
thus the same kind of principle can be
understood with this hadith of the dates
which is that in general yes you eat the
seven dates
and yes you will be protected and
immunized from these things
by allah's will so long as there's no
manner so long as there's no preventer
in much the same way
as you ask allah for whatever you like
so long as it's halal
and it's not doing haram and allah will
answer you so long as there's no manna
there's no preventer and that's
impossible to disprove from a scientific
perspective and i hope that answers the
question wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi
today insha'allah we're going to be
talking about one of the most species
claims that has come out of this
science narrative science era narrative
which is this claim that there's a
hadith of the prophet
which supposedly says that the earth is
on the back of a whale and the
whalers on the back over is balancing on
some kind of a rock or something to this
effect
and this hadith is fabricated i mean i
don't want to waste too much time with
this video and just be honest with you
this hadith is absolutely weak weak and
it's sanad
it's chained and weak in its content
it's
uh what it's saying if you look at the
senate let's start with that the chain
of narration we'll know that
uh it has in abdullah bin waheb it has
in the abdullah
all of those individuals all of them
without exception are weak narrators
and in fact even the cathedral mentions
in his video at the beginning and the
end
that this is a fabrication that is taken
from the israelite from the
uh kind of tales of the uh
judo christian uh tradition of those
individuals from that tradition
so this is something which is absolutely
fabricated it's
weak in in chain is weak in narration
it's weak in content
because no doubt this is some kind of a
mythological hadith but why can't you
find something like this in the quran
this is
really interesting i mean it's so easy
for everybody i think
that that that accesses this kind of
hadith to note that this
is absolutely unscientific and whatever
you want to say about this uh
you can't really it's indefensible
really this the meton the content of
this hadith
and why can't we find something like
that so glaringly obviously
against the observable reality in the
quran and the authentic sunnah
why do people have to resort to getting
something which is fabricated in order
to make a case against islam
do you think and this is another issue
when you look at one of the compendious
uh exegetical works of tabari and other
individuals
where they actually intentionally pour
all the material in there including the
weak and fabricated material
so that the scholar who is trained and
able to distinguish between the weak
and the fabricated narrations on the one
hand the matruk
and so on these kinds of varying levels
of inauthenticity
and they also put in there the authentic
hadith do you think that as an
unqualified personnel that you are the
detractor of islam coming into some
tafsir just because it's narrated from
that tafsir
that has somehow become authentic no
this is not how it works and this is why
the
when the untrained hand reaches into the
scholarly works of the muslims this is
the kind of blunders that they make but
in fact what they show
is that they have to resort desperately
resort
to to these kind of fabricated
narrations that nobody
accepts is absolutely embarrassing
narration
but why can't you find something so
glaringly
against the observable reality as this
there's nothing that you'll find in the
quran and once again the authentic
sunnah
that is like that but nice try no
today inshallah we're going to be
talking about a contention a
misconception a misnomer
something which you'll find in some of
the anti-islamic websites or
in anti-muslim or anti-islamic
apologetics
the claim that look your religion they
say is a religion which says that you
have to go
and drink the urine of camels
and the milk and urine of camels what
kind of medieval practice is this
we have come a long way in by way of
pharmacology
and medicine and look your religion
wants to bring us back
your religion wants to bring us back to
the
dark ages this is
what they claim but is this a true claim
and what are they basing this claim on
they're basing this claim
on a hadith it's a bihari where some
individuals came to the prophet muhammad
having some kind of a disease and
complaining of severe pain
and torment from that disease and they
came to him and he advised them
to go and drink the camel the urine of
the camel and drink the milk of the
camel
now one might argue that this is
completely you know unscientific
and this why would he do such a thing
why would the prophet muhammad
do such a thing is there any kind of
scientific backing for this at all
well first and foremost we need to
understand that this hadith is not ham
it's haas it's not uh general but
specific
it was specific to those people in that
time in that place
i mean if the prophet muhammad in this
time in the 21st century
i'm pretty certain that he would have
referred those individuals to the
hospitals
or to the pharmacies but you have to
remember that this was
situation specific so those individuals
that came there
the question is what might they have had
what kind of conditions might they have
had no we can speculate we can say that
they might have had edema or some kind
of fluid buildup in the stomach and in
the liver
we can we can make those things because
camel urine
is rich in potassium potassium um and
it's also rich in
albumin and quite frankly urine is
something which we find in some
medication
i mean primarine is a medication
which takes in which takes in as part of
this uh
one of the components of this medication
is the urine of mare
pregnant actually pregnant male urine so
this is not a foreign concept of using
urine for medications even today in the
21st century
but it's not to say that we as muslims
when we're not suffering from anything
and we have all of the facilitation by
way of medical advancement in 21st
century
should be going and drinking camel urine
and going to drink
the urine uh sorry the milk of the camel
as a way to try and
alleviate our illnesses and the evidence
of this is so
so clear in the quran
go and ask the people of specialism if
you don't know the quran says
thereby giving authority to doctors the
prophet muhammad
tells us to go to those reputable
doctors
and he even says those
whoever tries to be a doctor and is not
someone
who is known in medicine
or as a practitioner of medicine and
he's and he harms somebody or kill
someone then he will be
punished for so doing so there is clear
direction redirection from the islamic
uh paradigm
of move of going to those specialists
those medical specialists for our needs
so no this is not a a general uh
uh kind of directive from the prophet or
prescription of the prophet
in fact even the medieval scholars like
jose make this very clear in their
tracts
and their kutub and their books about
the prophetic medicine and so on and so
that this is
a specific kind of remedy for a specific
kind of people in a specific kind of
context
and yes we can try and speculate as to
what these individuals may have had and
what that prescription that so-called
if you want to put it as a prescription
would have had uh
in by way of relieving effect to those
individuals so
really there's no there's no way you can
go
in this criticism because what can you
say that potassium and albumin
and or calcium whatever it is in the
cocktail of prescriptions that i promise
all those individuals would have had no
relieving effects for
absolutely any disease that can uh come
in you can't make that claim
unfortunately
you'd have to be making that claim you'd
have to say for you to have a kind of
valid scientific argument here if you
want to call it that
you'd have to say that this cocktail of
prescriptions that the prophet gave to
those individuals
would have been useless in any disease
that those individuals would have had
and that's an impossible
claim because we know that there are
nutrients they're nutrient rich
those things that cocktail of uh things
that we've just talked about the camel
urine and the milk
has potassium albumin and other things
so unless you want to be brave enough to
make a claim like that which can be
easily refuted
and has been really if you think about
what i've just said then i would say
stop being immature if urine is part of
the drugs that we take consume in the
21st century this is not a way of
disproving the prophethood of prophet
muhammad
really what this is is a cheap way of
trying to mock the religion of islam
and the prophet of islam but the joke is
on you
oh detractor because the truth of the
matter the reality of the situation
is that the prophet and islam gives us
clear directives
to go to those who are specialists in
the field including of course
medical professionals
today inshallah we're going to be
discussing the issue of geocentrism
in the quran or the supposed geocentrism
that the detractors had
supposedly found in the quran all over
the verses in the quran
that is so glaringly obvious for us that
we have not been able to detect it
but let's take a look at this claim and
see how honest it is
whether it's actually isolated in nature
what is the claim the claim is that in
the quran in those verses where
the orbits of the sun and the moon are
mentioned
that this indicates to us at least
uh it implies to us maybe in implicit
reference
or inference that the sun is going
around the earth this is their claim
so what kind of verses do they use
before i get to what kind of verses
they use we should point to the fact
that we've done
an entire video on the hadith of
prostration of abu dhabi
and this can be found in the description
box below
and you should be looking at inshallah
also if you have your time
all the other videos we've done in this
series because potentially
we have other answers because a lot of
these videos are actually intertwined in
terms of the
themes and content of these videos so
let's move on and talk about
where in fact they're talking about this
uh
these um geocentric references in the
quran
so they'll they'll mention for example
chapter number 39 verse number 5.
he rolls the day into the night and he
rolls the night into the day
and he has made the sun move subservient
for you and each of them are running in
an obey
so does this mean to say from this verse
or other verses but let's go with this
verse first that the sun is going around
the earth no there is no such indication
at all the only way
in this verse and we'll see in other
verses that they quote that you can come
to the conclusion that is saying
that the sun is going around the earth
is if you impose you superimpose
that understanding you have already had
a preconceived understanding of
geocentrism in the quran
and now you are trying to force that
interpretation onto the quran you will
not find quite frankly
you will not find quite frankly any
verse in the quran
which simply states the sun goes around
the earth and how easy
would it have been for such a verse to
be there look at
surah champs chapter number 91 of the
quran
will
the sun and as it illuminates the day or
the the the rays of the light
and as the moon follows the sun now does
this mean it's
following in a in a geocentric orbit no
it doesn't have to mean that because
in islamic cosmology we know that the
the day follows the night
and the night follows the day and that's
the anthropocentric
phenomenological perspective we see that
the night
these are sequences that we see from our
perspective
but actually quite frankly the sun the
moon does actually follow the sun
i mean a lot of these individuals have
not even touched have not even
touched the basics of cosmology
uh i mean i don't know it's very
surprising that they're making all these
scientific claims and they don't realize
that the sun is not just stationary it's
revolving around its own axis and it's
running through
the fabric of space taking with it all
of those
planets are around it and of course all
the moons that exist within the solar
system as well so
in in reality the the moon is actually
following the sun
and also it from our perspective the
moon is following the sun look at the
beauty
and the brevity and the conciseness
of the quranic expression such that an
individual doesn't have to
do a hermeneutical acrobatics or
hermeneutical gymnastics in order to
come to a conclusion like this
we're not trying to force things into
the book they also mentioned chapter
number 21 verse number 33
where it says that yes behind the sun
and the moon it says that all of it is
in a phallic
yes but that's true the sun does have a
phallic
the moon does have a phallic how is that
wrong from a heliocentric perspective
once again the argument is so lacking
quite frankly so lacking is actually
i was contemplating whether or not to
dignify this with a response
i really was because it's so weak
now what is the strongest part of their
argument let me discuss it with you
the strongest part of their argument
which is not strong at all but let's
just go with it
it's those parts of the argument where
they mentioned for example
the kisla or the story of ibrahim
alaihissalam and his interaction with
which is in chapter number two verse
number 258
where where allah no ibrahim
the sun from the east so bring it from
the west and so this nimrod this king
that he was having a conversation with
the interlocutor
was not able to do so and then he was
dumbfounded and bedazzled
and he realized you know he was
dumbstruck if you want to call it that
whatever it may be
the one who just believed they say look
it's saying here from the east and from
the west and therefore
the assumption is a stationary earth and
that the sun is going around the earth
really because let's look at chapter
number 18 verse number 17.
what allah says
that you see that when those individuals
are in the cave you see the sun
when it has rise it goes to the left of
them
and when it sets it goes to the right of
them
when it's uh setting it's going at the
left so it's the right one
when it's rising and the left one is
setting now what is right and left
take about this for a second right and
left will be
absolutely useless references unless
there is a point of reference
what do you mean by that even on a
stationary earth
model or a stationary stationary flat
earth or a stationary round earth
whatever you want to say
the the the right and left have no
meaning
unless we're talking about a specific
reference point
and if the quran is talking about the
right and left of them
yes then this is perspectival
there's no doubt about that then it has
to be through the perspective
of those individuals there and what in
what perspective is it it's the
anthropocentric phenomenological
perspective
it has to be like that otherwise it
wouldn't make sense it would be
meaningless statements
from the left and the right because
yeah i mean if you don't understand this
this shows illiteracy
intellectual illiteracy intellectual
uh foolishness
clear clearly is from the
anthropocentric perspective from the
human perspective as a reference point
so if you look at all of those verses in
the quran something quite interesting
for your information
that if you look at chapter number 36
verse number 40 and that's actually
funny enough
funny enough and interestingly enough
that's something they also mentioned
chapter number 36 number 40 uh
before and even the literalists are
literally scholars like
you want to call him a militarist or
whatever you want to call him
uh he looked at this verse and he says
it starts from
i think it was verse number 24 or
something like this when allah says
that a sign for them is the
the dead earth so he moves from the
earth and then he goes to the sun
where shamsu
he makes the claim that and
linguistically this is possible lingus
is absolutely possible
it's conjunctive so it could absolutely
be the case
that the the earth the sun and the moon
all of them are in orbit
and that is linguistically possible
we're not going to say just men
like absolutely this is the case but
it's a possibility
and from all of those perspectives and
more we show that the quran is a
timeless book
with multi-layered facilitation meaning
that if someone from the 7th century
were to look at it
and approach it with their naturalistic
understanding and outlook
they would not be confused and one when
someone from our
from from our century 21st century looks
at it we would not be confused and we
don't even find it quite frankly against
the cosmology of
uh of today or the popular cosmologies
of today so from all of those
perspectives and more
it would seem that they are clutching at
straws trying their best
really trying their best to force an eye
to jesus of the quran
with their superimpositions and their
contriving
their pretextual contriving
into the verses of the quran and i would
say that this is a fool's attempt
and it has been disproven and debunked
and it should be uh left in the dustbin
of history and i hope this answers the
question
today in charlotte we're going to be
talking about another claim that is made
by the proponents of scientific miracles
and we're not saying by the way that all
of their claims are false we're saying
that
the method itself has limitations and
we've discussed this the limitations
of the methods in the uh in the video
about big bang and there will be a
discussion
another video about the multilayered
approach
which is we believe a more sophisticated
approach to dealing with naturalistic
verses in the quran
but in terms of this now the uh the
claim that is usually made
when trying to prove islam is scientific
is a claim
in chapter number 79 verse number 30
where allah says
and they said or they they translate
this to mean and the earth we have made
it into an ostrich eric egg
now this is a false translation with all
due respect to all of those who are
making this or saying this
it's a false translation which is why to
my knowledge i don't think anybody has
ever translated that into the english
language
in this way and not only this but we
would see that
all of the exegetes of whole time in the
medieval period
practically all of them or none of them
had said anything like this
so this is probably one of the worst
examples with all due respect once again
of distortion and superimposition and
contriving
meanings into the verse which are not
actually there in any way shape or form
form so what does this verse actually
mean it means that allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala has smoothed over the earth
in other words he hasn't made it
craterous in such a way as the moon is
for example we can move around the earth
and there are flat surfaces all over the
earth now
why do these individuals or what
potential tenuous link
could individuals make between an
ostrich egg
and this verse well an ostrich egg is
referred
not even the ostrich by the way sorry
the place where in which and this is the
uh degree of uh tenuousness uh
in this in this attempt here the place
where in which
the ostrich lays this egg is called a
mud
this is called that not not the ostrich
egg the bella
itself of the nana not the ostrich egg
itself
but the place in which the ostrich puts
this egg
is called now this isn't a noun but this
verb
in the sorry this verse in the in this
in the area
is not mentioning a noun so how can you
translate it as a noun
because the verse is a verb
to it is
is feminine in the arabic language
so allah has smoothed over and he's kind
of removed the creators or has made it
not remove the creators it hasn't made
it craters in such same way as maybe the
moon is
or has put so many mountains that would
find difficulty to move around
in the environment this is what is
practically all the mufassiron have said
from a tabari
i haven't seen anybody quite frankly who
has understood this meaning
to mean that it's a place where the
where the air oh sorry the
the earth is made into an egg now this
doesn't mean that the earth is
projected in the quran as uh being flat
as we've said before there's there is
precedent
using verses from the quran using verses
from the quran
that indicate the rotinity of the
authority sorry all the roundness of the
earth and
we have actually an entire video which
you can see in the description box which
elaborates upon them
but briefly i'll just mention that this
is chapter number 39 verse number five
you call it
he rose the night into the day and he
rose the day into the night so
taquir here comes from the arabic word
quran which means bull
and this is what even hasan uh in his
book el fisal
he mentions he mentions that this and by
the way he was like fourth century or
fifth century
so he is a medieval scholar that came
before
you know the scientific revolutions and
he said he used this verse
he used this verse in surah zumar
chapter number 39 verse number 5
to indicate that the earth is round and
this is not just him
we talked about ibn tamiya mentioning
tabi's like even moneta
who say that the earth is round and in
fact he says it's ishmael it's a
consensus
not only this but even josie who we
mentioned in the previous video about
the big bang
ibn jose it also mentions the authority
of the earth
many scholars does and he's
many other people do and they they they
they can do this
like i've just mentioned with him hasan
by looking at verses of the quran which
linguistically indicate the rotanity of
the earth now having said this
okay we've said that there's this
difference of opinion and we're not
saying that no one in islamic history
has ever said that the earth is flat
and there have been individuals that
have tried to use the quran to indicate
the flatness of the earth
that might be true as well but we always
say
that is definitely not the only
interpretation and islam is quite unique
quite frankly in that
it has exegetes who use verses from it
to indicate the alternative of the earth
whereas you'll find uh
in in other scriptures like for example
the old testament uh and the new
testament
the patristic scholarship all the way up
to probably uh augustine that have
done exit jesus of the bible on these
matters none of them
uh probably up until the time of
augustine believed that the earth was
round anyway
and those who did never use verses from
the bible including that
tenuous verse in uh the book of isaiah
uh chapter number 40 where it says the
circle of the earth
no one understood the circle of the
earth as meaning the ball of the earth
and therefore no one used the bible
in uh in patricia's scholarship as we
see as we can see
by looking at all of the exegesis uh in
the first 300 years of christianity
using the bible or even the the midrash
the uh the the the jewish texts which
are
which were written quite uh
astonishingly and interestingly enough
sometimes after the patristic texts were
executed
they don't use the biblical verses to
indicate the rotundity of the earth or
the spherical nature of the earth
if they do believe it it might be due to
the fact they they had greek influence
and this tenuous verse the circle of the
earth does not
and has not meant for the uh
the authors of uh midrash meaning the
uh the the the exodus jesus of the old
testament to mean rotunda
and there's no scholar that has ever
used in the first 300 years of
christianity or even in the midrash
any verse to indicate that the earth is
round in the bible well there have been
uh scholars who have used verses from
the quran
very early scholars to indicate that the
earth is round
now why am i saying this because i'm
offering a solution but what i don't
what we can't endorse with all due
respect is superimpositions onto the sex
and i actually believe a retraction is
necessary here
because there is no precedent for this
there's no precedent for anyone saying
that this verse means and we have made
the earth ostrich egged
no one has said that would you respect
and therefore we have to be humble
and we have to be sincere and we have to
make a retraction here
because this is the quran we're talking
about and allah says
he mentions many things and of the worst
things that you can do and he says
at the end of the verse
that you say about allah which you don't
know and so this is not what allah has
intended because it's not
facilitated by the language and there
should be a healthy retraction
by those proponents of the scientific
miracle narrative
who have said this um who have said this
ostrich
there should be a retraction because we
can't be demanding from all of those
scientific era people
okay the anti-muslims anti-islam
apologists all these retractions and not
be introspective and self-reflective in
our own communities
and we have to try and get yani sanctify
the words of allah subhanahu ta'ala as
much as we can and these are the dangers
of the scientific miracles narrative
where you almost forcibly superimpose
meanings
of science into the into the text where
there's no requirement to do so because
there's actually
healthy alternatives with great
precedent and which are facilitated by
the language
in the very quran that we believe in so
uh
this uh one of the weakness uh
weaknesses of the scientific miracles
narrative but as i've said in the
beginning of this video
that we will be talking about the
multi-layered approach and how it solves
these problems and more
and it's much more sophisticated and it
doesn't fall into the pitfalls
uh of the scientific miracles narrative
that we've seen for the last uh maybe 20
years
and i hope that answers the question was
salaam alaika
today in sha allah we're going to be
talking about the big bang and whether
or not the quran
talks about the big bang or actively
teaches the big bang
and of course this is a ubiquitous kind
of claim that you find
with those who espouse the scientific
miracles narrative
both in the western world in the
english-speaking world and of course the
middle east as well i'm sure in other
parts of the world
that i don't have access to
unfortunately because my language skills
are limited
but let's say let's answer this question
the question of whether the quran or not
actively speaks about the big bang
before we do this though i think it's
very important to
note that here at sapiens institute we
think that the most sophisticated
way of dealing with the quran in in so
much as
it talks about the naturalistic
phenomena of the world is to apply
a multi-layered approach and this
approach really says that the quran
speaks in a simple and concise yet
powerful and rich
way which communicates with different uh
audiences from the 7th century
all the way through to the 21st century
and it also says
that when we're looking at verses when
we're looking at verses we need to allow
ambiguities to remain as ambiguities in
other words
picking one uh of many different
interpretations and claiming that this
is a scientific miracle is a limitation
now obviously this method requires or
the multi-layered method requires a
video in its own right it deserves
more attention and of course we're going
to we're going to do that but
for the purposes of today we're not
going to be going into much depth
uh however there's one more thing i
think is important to put forward in
terms of conceptual analysis
which is david schatz uh his
conceptional
compartmentalization of concordism into
two different types now what is
concordism
concordism loosely defined is
the propensity of a scripture whether
it's the bible or the quran whatever
to be in agreement with science or to
actually actively teach science now
david chats divides it into two
different things
he refers to as bold concordism and
modest concordism
so bold concordism is really the
postulation that the scripture is
actively speaking about
said scientific phenomena and modest
concordance is that the scripture
may not speak about it in such explicit
terms
but indeed is not against it in such
explicit terms or
whatever said phenomena is i think the
modest concordance position is much
more tenable from a hermeneutical and
exegetical perspective
now let's move on to this uh this big
bang example and
and look at the verses so obviously this
is chapter number 21 verse number 30
where allah subhanahu ta'ala says you
know that the unit the heavens and the
earth
they were both one piece so we separated
them this is a loose translation and
it's a very legitimate translation
because if you look at
the exegetes like tabari and even kefir
and
all of these major kind of exegetes of
the past
and obviously also the arabic language
and
for something to be together and for
them to be separated
however when you look at what these
exegetes say they do actually
um expound on different types of meaning
so for example
yes it does say that the heavens and the
earth were together and then we
cleared them asunder or have we
separated them or whatever you want to
translate it
but they also say that this could mean
that this is when
the the same or the skies started to
rain
and when the uh grounds started to
produce vegetation
this is another extra jesus that is of
the same verse and many of the salaf and
many of those
medieval commentators took this as the
as the primary meaning in fact and that
is why
the next verse talks about we have made
for more to every living thing that says
it makes more sense in that sense
but we will leave both of those
interpretations as valid interpretations
now those interpretations and more have
been said about this verse
so to choose one of them are we
justified in choosing one of them
because the
dominant scientific theory of the day
is espouses or is closer to that one of
them
i think we should be more reserved and
conservative with this because quite
frankly
of all the different kinds of sciences
that are out there you could argue
making
a strong argument that physics and
especially astronomy is the most
volatile in terms of change i mean
paradigm shifts
we know not only the newtonian to
einsteinian shift but
all kinds of theories have been
elaborated upon in the last 100 years in
science and astronomy i mean string
theory oscillating universe
eternal universes i mean you can see
from the from the writings of some of
the
most prominent scientists that we have
like roger penrose for example
and in 10 or 20 years he changes his
mind on very foundational issues when it
comes to cosmology
therefore to pin you know a verse in the
quran on the
changing and courageable and
moving if you like scientific discourse
i think is quite dangerous because
what if in in 50 years in 70 years or
100 years
the dominant cosmology is different and
that is a very plausible scientific
possibility
it's extremely plausible for the
dominant
cosmology to have shifted and for this
reason this for me defines
another limitation of saying that the
quran talks about the big bang theory
which is that okay if you're saying this
today let's see if you remain consistent
maybe if your grandchildren remain
consistent that have the same
methodology where all of these western
scientists
are now changing their mind and it
becomes an oscillating theory
and then maybe you go to another
interpretation but this movement
uh of science and also the fact that
there are different interpretations
kind of says to me that we shouldn't be
cherry-picking verses and trying to make
them match
you know the interpretations match with
modern-day scientific phenomena
because if we do that we're actually
outlining a
failed hermeneutic and we are actually
justifying for those
individuals who are attacking islam the
detractors of islam
who use one of many uh interpretations
which might be unscientific and
legitimate through the language
that this is a legitimate recourse so if
we're saying that we will
we'll take one of many different
interpretations and now we're going to
elaborate upon that
then that what that does is it opens the
can of worms because now
the uh the detractor or anti-muslim
apologist is
well justified in saying that according
to the quran
the heaven oh sorry the earth was
created before the heaven for example
and this is the opinion of this person
and that that person well
we'll come back and say well hold on the
opinion of the other person and that
person
is opposite to that well they'll say
well hold on you have justified to
yourself
taking an ambiguous verse and and saying
that it means this
when there are these other alternate
linguistic alternatives and exegetical
alternatives so why are we not within
our rights
to choose unscientific interpretations
and say this is what it means
well in fact this whole idea of using
ambiguous verses which have more than
one interpretation
and running with it is exactly the
opposite exactly the opposite of what
allah tells us to do in the quran
it says that this book has verses which
are foundational and others which are
ambiguous
for those people who have swerving in
their hearts or some kind of deviance in
their hearts they'll choose
yes those interpretations that they
which are ambiguous and they don't know
what the the verse goes on to say they
don't know what these interpret no one
knows
what these the interpretation actually
definitely definitively means except for
allah
and some say what also those who are
very
grounded in knowledge and some say no
not even those because the sentence
starts and that's another discussion
but the idea is that choosing one of
many different interpretations and
insisting
that this is what the quran says is not
the the sophisticated hermeneutical
method
and in fact it can go into what
you may say about allah which you don't
know it may go into that
or it could go into what the prophet
says
whoever lies about me intentionally then
let him prepare his sea in the hellfire
where you know that there are other
interpretations but you're intentionally
choosing one
so you can fit it with a particular
narrative and so this is problematic so
from all of those perspectives that you
have
changing science that it's a
cherry-picking approach
that you know it's limited and you know
you could even say one of the possible
assumptions i'm not saying it's a
definitive or something
is that if it is talking about the big
bang if let's say that chapter 21 verse
number 30
is talking about the big bang if it is
talking about the big bang
does that mean to say that those people
in the 7th century who had no knowledge
of astronomy
would have had this verse or the meaning
of this veil to them
like they wouldn't understand the
implications of the big bang and so this
verse would
be meaningless or very very close to
being meaningless to them
so that would be a yani uh this this
could be something which is also
damaging
the truth of the matter is this verse
does indicate to us that there was some
kind of separation but we don't know
what exactly cosmologically it's talking
about
and similarly
you know the the heaven we have in
chapter 51 of quran the heaven we have
created it with power
and we we are steadily expanding it now
yes there are some people
even tabbers that i've looked at the
tephazil in the exegetes that say that
uh musa one doesn't mean expanding there
are some tabernacles who say that
like for example abdul rahman bin zayd
even islam and i've read this in
even josie's kittep
and so this is definitely represented in
the literature i'm not taking that away
from
uh from from that however there's a few
issues it says what's um
dunya for example and we know and we've
talked about this in other episodes that
so that means all that is
all that is above and so this does not
necessitate that it's just a worldly
dunya that we associate with the
universe so this might be talking about
something which is completely above and
beyond our understanding because we
haven't even
accessed the other six heavens for
example and it could be talking
something above the sixth heavens
because sama
could involve the corsi and technically
so why are we getting ourselves okay
it's talking about the expanding
universe for sure
we don't know allahu allah if it's
talking about the expanding universe for
sure because
quite frankly the majority of exegete
says
means we are able to do so like we are
able to do so
allah we created the heaven with power
and we were able to do so
and there's no contradiction between the
two meanings and yes it could mean both
but to insist it's talking about the
expanding universe in redshift
i think it's a bit uh is a bit much and
if you do insist is definitely talking
about this and this is how we should
understand the verse
then once again the cherry picking
approach and the inconsistencies of it
you'd have to afford for the hasam for
the interlocutor
which in this case will be the
anti-muslim apologist who's going to use
unscientific interpretations in much the
same way as you're using scientific ones
so what needs to be done here is we need
to remain consistent
and we will we need to understand the
limits
of of using this kind of evidence
and quite frankly in the last 20 or 30
years we've seen the the strengths and
uh
uh with weaknesses of this the
advantages and disadvantages the
advantages if you from a dower
perspective quite frankly if you try and
bring people into islam because of this
those people that you bring into islam
because of this will be most affected by
the anti-islamic apologists
when they provide for them for for them
equal or similar types of argumentation
using equal or similar
uh methods and so it
could and we have seen and we have the
evidence that it could increase apostasy
for those particular individuals
who have been convinced of islam because
of that reason so one has to
exercise extreme caution here and they
have to be
consistent and they have and they have
to do justice to the quran
and leave that which is ambiguous as
ambiguous and speak with
um speak with with a sophisticated
tongue
not when when it's an ambiguous verse
because no one knows really
what this verse exactly is talking about
and i hope that answers the question
but finally i will say as the muslims
can we believe in the big bang and can
we believe in the expanding universe
and redshift in the beginning of the
universe absolutely i don't see any
problem with that and in other videos
you see that we're talking about for
example the the days meaning something
which is longer
an epoch or generational time period so
it doesn't need to mean
a 24-hour period so from those
perspectives i see no harm
in believing the big bang theory so long
as you believe that allah is the one who
created or
who initiated it yeah i don't see any
issue
with believing it so long as allah is
the orchestrator of it and he is this is
part of his hulk
but you should uh from a scientific
perspective be a little bit more
uh less eager and a bit more use the
word agnostic really because we don't
know for sure
how far this big bang theory is uh
is true because quite frankly it's
underdetermined from a
philosophy of science perspective
there's like maybe 16 or 17
differing models with very similar
epistemic weight
and so this under determination should
allow us to realize
that from an islamic perspective and
it's not qatari
and therefore we should not which means
it's speculative and it's not something
which is
certain and so we shouldn't need to
feel the need to really uh
overcompensate here with this issue
and i hope that answers the question of
salaam alaikum so
today inshaallah we're going to be
tackling a contention that some of these
anti-islamic apologists have tried to
put forth
one that stipulates or that asserts we
could say
that the quranic presentation of
cosmology is one that says that the sun
it sets into a murky water spring
and why do they say that because of a
verse in surah chapter
18 of the quran one of the protagonists
one of the
characters of the quran he goes to a
certain destination and he says
that he sees the sun in hamilton
he saw the sun setting in a muddy spring
and they say this shows because uh it's
very clear in the quran they would argue
that this shows that the sun according
to the quranic cosmology
yes uh setting in a spring of uh
murky water now let's let's look at what
the mufassiron the
exegetes of the quran are four times
have said look at bayley look
even though he didn't do like a you know
a tafsir of the quran but he mentions
this
by mentioning that all of the spheres of
the the the phallic are muslim or are
spherical
and according actually mentions in his
tafsir that this
yani because obviously he was preaching
or he was
his homiletic type of exegesis was also
being preached to a non-arab audience
and a lot of individuals they didn't
understand that the word vegeta could
actually mean
is perspectivalist from the perspective
of the individual he said this obviously
not talking about the sun
which is many many times bigger than the
earth which we live in
sinking into the yani the uh the spring
of uh
of murky water in that literalistic
sense and what is the evidence
of this from the arabic language the
evidence of this is the word
which is what the word the operative
word that is used in this verse
it means one of the key meanings of it
according to allah
who wrote obviously one of the most
authoritative
dictionaries for referencing the arabic
language uh
al fatima for the quran he says in it
that this
wajada could mean anything from the five
senses
so it's perspectival it's something from
the five senses that is experienced from
the
person experiencing them so this wajada
is clearly in the arabic language
perspectival
and it's the anthropocentric
phenomenological perspective and so from
this perspective it seems to me that
this is
really flogging at that horse or trying
to put into the quran what they wish
really was clear in the quran and that
they hoped was already in there now you
imagine
sometime after today maybe 100 years
from now or 200 years from now
some atheists that live on if the world
continues
that period of time as they say look at
these fools that lived in the 21st
century they used to say that the sun
sets but we know from modern science
that the sun doesn't say
we'll say that these people are foolish
they don't understand how language works
because sunset in the english language
because it's not something foreign
sunset is is obviously from our
perspective it's a linguistic
kind of not idiom but it's something
which is
common speech and it's not intended in
that literalistic way
so we would be saying that to them
obviously why can't you apply the same
kind of common sense with the quranic
discourse
it's because you're begging you're
you're desperate
to find some kind of thing an entrance
point for your narratives and this is
weak
another thing that i would add or that
they say
is that what there's another hadith
which corroborates our understanding
which is the hadith when the prophet was
asked supposedly asked
where does the sunset and he says that
it goes into a spring of muddy water now
this
loves of the hadith this particular
phraseology of the hadith
was um was narrated by one individual
called
al-haqim nartaba who is seen as a
modalis which means that he's weak
basically this individual does something
called
which means that he doesn't tell us
where he gets his information from
he doesn't tell us who his teacher is
and so this
is a form of disqualification from the
hadith science perspective
and so this particular phraseology is
not to be understood as
strong the and that's why it's not
mentioned bukhari muslim in fact
the hadith which is mentioned bukhari is
the one that we talked about in the
other
in the other video which of course you
can watch in conjunction with this one
if you want more information
the hadith of prostration now if one
argues that even though this is the case
we can do
to the hadith or some kind of
strengthening of this hadith
and there are some scholars that say
this hadith is strong and so on and so
forth
well we can say that if you want to play
with weak hadiths and weak narrations
we can also bring forward
which is actually weak uh but can be
argued to be strong in the same or
similar senses that this one
where it says washington
that the sun runs and it has no place of
setting
there's actually something which is
attributed to both of abbas
and evidens now one can argue if we do
take this on board wouldn't this run
counter to what the quran says
washington
that it runs to a a place of uh
appointed for it well actually
the jama could be made or contra
distinction can be made between a
harmonization could be made between the
two
in so much as we can say that one is
talking about time
or the day of judgement in the case of
the the which is well known and the
other one is talking about place
and of course we can make those
arguments but i won't make those
arguments because we have to stick with
the integrity of the islamic tradition
of
authenticating that which is authentic
and leaving inauthentic that which is
inauthentic it does not have
the um the apparatus for being something
which is an authentic hadith that should
be taken as
a gospel if you like or in this case
for the muslim so uh i would say that if
you want to play with weak hadees we can
all play with weak hadith and weak
generations and with
and in fact the one that i have is much
clearer in
by way of trying to prove the
heliocentric model than the one that
they have
by way of trying to prove that the sun
actually literally
sets in the spring of muddy water and
this of course runs counter to the
islamic understanding or the quranic
reading
where it says that the sun is in its own
orbit in chapter number 21 verse number
33 in chapter number 36 verse number 40
in chapter in many different chapters
number 35 verse number 39 verse number
five
different places so in summary therefore
this is a weakened
feeble contention a species claim which
i hope now has been
uh completely and utterly refuted and
hopefully that answers the question
today inshallah we're going to be
talking about a contention
which is put forward by some of those
detractors namely one that talks about
the noah's ark
narrative now obviously we know this
narrative is also in the bible
but this specific narrative or this
specific uh contention i should say
is leveled directly at the quran in
particular level that
chapter 11 verse 40 of the quran where
allah subhanahu ta'ala says
that bring on it mean kulin's o jainism
from
every pair or every kind a pair from
every kind
a pair male and female so they say it's
virtually impossible to fit
all the species of the earth all the
species
male and female on this ship what kind
of ship
would this be anyway it's virtually
impossible to put all these animals and
when we say pear
i mean they're saying from every it's
not even saying animals yeah it's the
same we call
in so jaina's name from every
kind or i mean cullen anything that can
have a pair really
so jane its name now do we understand
this
literalistically so the answer to this
question is this
the operative words here min kullin
zojay anything or kul the word kullu in
the arabic language which literally
means
every in one of the translations of this
term
is what is the source of confusion
because
some people read this and have a very
literalistic
interaction with this word this word
does not
only mean this word in the arabic
language
does not only mean every single thing
it can also mean many things and what is
the evidence of this
the evidence of this can be found in the
quran itself
where in chapter 46 and surah al-aqf of
the quran
in verse number 25 allah says to
that it destroys everything with the
command
of your lord it's talking about a wind
for us
so they could not be seen except for
their places
of inhabitational residence
so in other words it's not talking about
everything because this verse is being
very clear
that this wind destroyed many types of
things
it destroys
everything the same words here
the word kul is there meaning every
right
it destroys everything so
nothing of the them was seen except for
their homes
we can't see anything except for their
places of residency
their homes so clearly this is not
talking about everything this wind
didn't destroy the universe
the cosmos and this and that and almost
every
osuli uh this is a branch of islamic
sciences called us
which is the principles of jurisprudence
they use this in their tracks and their
treatises the word cool and
it's called it's actually a category of
thing called elam
let's use
that it's something which is general and
what is intended from it is a specific
thing
so it's a kind of usage of the language
which was understood by the scholars of
islam
one of the scholars of islam assyuti who
died 911
after hijri he in fact wrote a book
about this word
kul uh al kulum this is the name of the
book
and in it he shows that there are usages
of the word kul which
is literalistically translated as every
which
cannot mean every single such that
nothing
is excluded from that particular genus
or circumstance whatever is we're
talking about universal whatever it is
we're talking about
and so with this i should say one more
thing
that as i started this discussion a lot
of people are taking the genesis
narrative and putting onto the quran
there are some very many differences for
example
a literal reading not a literalistic one
by literal reading of genesis
may take someone who's an evangelical or
who takes a literal understanding of the
bible
like answers in genesis and those
individuals to the conclusion
that the whole world was consumed by
flood
and that all individuals had to be put
on the ship
or and animals and everything had to be
put on the ship
that is a a an interpretation
for the bible we are under no obligation
to believe that it was a worldwide flood
and we are under an obligation to
believe that all the
entire worlds animals and species have
to be put on the ship for the reasons
aforementioned
but i hope with that the contention is
cleared
and with that i end this episode
wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi
today we're going to be responding to a
contention which
some people anti-islamic apologists have
used
and even since on some of their websites
about a hadith
which talks about the black seed and if
you wanted to translate it
literalistically it would read
that it's a cure for every disease
but is this the case how could it be the
case i mean is it a cure for cancer for
aids
for all of those things do we not need
hospitals anymore
cancer research needs to shut down
because now we have the black seed no
the hadith does not mean uh all of the
diseases
barring none this is of course a
literalistic
reading of the hadith which has no
bearing
on the actual meaning of that hadith and
this is not even how the medieval
scholars the the
uh commentators of this hadith have
understood it
even from as far back as even
and others and the other individuals
like him
jose and others who spoke about
the black seed and this hadith in
particular all of which who
i've read anyway specified that it's not
talking about
all the diseases but it's talking about
many
different kinds of uh diseases and
this is something which we know from the
usage of the word
kul which is in this hadith which is
also used in the quran
while us mentions in surah
that it destroys there's a wind that
destroys everything
with the command of its lord so
they came to be not seen except for
their indwellings
and of course this does not mean that
this
wind that allah is talking about
is a wind that destroyed everything
including animals and the
earth and the cosmos even though
there's the exception there
except for their indwellings it doesn't
mean everything was destroyed except for
the indwelling so the
kul here is not intended by any means
or any stretch of the imagination
to mean every single thing
on the face of the earth let alone the
entire
existence or entire universe this is
impossible
to extrapolate from this verse and that
is why many of the scholars have
actually
written books and criticism about this
word kul
because many people that employ
literalistic
understandings of the arabic language
do not understand these kinds of usages
so sulti wrote a book
or the word kul and what it implies or
what its
evidences or shows so this
should be very clear now that the uh the
black seed is not
actually a cure for every single
disease except death it's not a cure for
every single disease because the prophet
muhammad told us that allah has not sent
down
any disease
except that he sent down with it
except that he sent down with it you
know a
cure in other words for every specific
disease
there is a level
he allah has prescribed for it
a cure a specific cure and thus
uh if if uh this was not the case and
black seed could solve all of our
problems
then such a hadith would indeed indeed
be a futile one
and would not make any sense so that is
why we have to look at
the entire corpus of hadith before
we rush to conclusions in summary
therefore
those individuals who try and use this
hadith and others to try and mock
islam and muslims are but surely
lost in their own ignorance and indeed
have
a very superficial understanding
newspaper understanding
cursory understanding of
the hadith tradition and i hope that is
intellectually
as satisfying as is for you as it has
been for me
was
today in sha allah what we're going to
be doing is dealing with a very
prominent hadith that you'll find in
many of the
anti-islamic apologetics and
anti-islamic
websites of those individuals who are
trying
to attack the deen the religion of islam
so this is a famous hadith really a
cosmological hadith
which is mentioned by abu dharr
al-khafari and the contention
is that this hadith fully supports
without
a shadow of a doubt a geocentric model
and in fact some add to this and say it
shows that the quranic picture that the
islamic cosmology
generally is that of not only a flat
earth which they've
said and spoken about and we have a
separate video on
but one which is flat and stationary and
where in which
the uh the sun is going around in a
geocentric way
and thus it's confirming the uh 7th
century
you know understanding of cosmology and
this is
an evidence that it's false so as i've
mentioned
the discussion of flat earth versus
round earth is in a separate video
which you can find on this series so if
you want to see me talk about that
you can pause the video now watch that
video and come back
now in regards to this particular video
let's read the hadith in question and
move on
to what the specific contentions are so
the hadith
is narrated by abu dhabi may allah be
pleased with him
and he said that the prophet sallallahu
alaihi wasallam said
do you know where the sun set
do you know where it goes i said
allah and his messenger know best he
said it goes and prostrates beneath
the throne then it asks for permission
to rise
and permission is given to it soon it
will prostrate
and it will ask for it for permission to
rise but permission
will not be given to it it will be said
to it go back to where you came from
so arise from its place of setting
and that is what allah may allah be
glorified may he be glorified
refers to in the verse and the son runs
on its fixed course for a term appointed
and that is a decree of the mighty the
all-knowing he's mentioning
uh the prophet muhammad mentioning an
ayah surah asi in chapter 36 verse
number 38
that the son runs on or on a fixed
term decreed so let's talk about what
the contentions are the contentions
really you could say
are three in number three main
contentions
the first one relates to this
prostration of the sun what do we
understand
from this uh hadith when we talk about
the prostration of the sun
is it to be suggested that this is an
anthropomorphic or a personified picture
of the celestial
sphere that is the sun and isn't this
more in line with mythology
and ancient legend than it is with the
scientific contemporaneous reality that
we know
from examination and from uh
advances in science that's number one
the second thing is about
that the the going how could the sun be
going
uh underneath the throne and this shows
they say
the fact that the sun is going somewhere
in sunset
that it's confirming they say the
geocentric picture
thirdly they say the time of sunset so
why is it that the time of sunset is in
any way significant
knowing that sunset is at different
times at different points of the round
earth
i know there may be some flat earthers
listening to this
and as i've said there's a video for you
guys or for other people
uh about the flowers these are the three
main contentions
so let's deal with them one by one and
in terms of verses of the quran
we'll be discussing those verses
of the quran which people try to use to
refer to geocentrism
in an entirely different video so the
first issue that people have
is in relation to prostration they say
what is this prostration
the quran says in chapter 17
that everything in the heavens and the
earth
you know glorifies allah and nothing
in the heavens and the earth does
anything but glorify
allah but you do not understand the way
in which
that takes place so this verse shows
that the celestial bodies the inanimate
objects all of those things
in the world whether living or not has a
means
of glorifying allah and this is actually
in the realm
of the metaphysical so science does not
tap into this
and it has nothing to do with science in
fact the quran explicitly says
well i can let's be hap
in other words the sun and the moon
and all the universe it has a way of
glorifying allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
which is distinctly different distinctly
different from the way in which we do so
so to try and impose and
anthropomorphize or personify
understanding on the celestial spheres
or the inanimate objects
is nothing but going against the quran
and a misunderstanding of the entirety
of the quran
so the prostration is not a prostration
like
you know where you put your head on the
floor or the fact that prostration
requires
stationary action from the human actor
in fact
with different uh species different
animals different inanimate objects
different spheres the the prostration
does not in any way need to be
correlated
with such human prostration it's not
like the sun is growing
arms and a forehead and is throwing
itself on the floor
this is not the understanding in fact
the quran refutes this understanding
very categorically so this very
literary it's not even literal it's a
literalistic reading
of the quran the hadith is is is the
first point
is the first point of confusion for
those individuals who try and ask about
the prostration
so clearly here the prostration is
referring to something which is
metaphysical and untappable by the
scientific method
and one can say that you know the
prostration not just the prostration
but the submission of the sun
the islam and the sujood of the sun
is expected since allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala
talks about that the heavens and the
earth will obey
allah
willingly or unwillingly in other words
they're obeying the laws of allah
subhanahu wa'ta'ala
now some individuals will say so why
does the hadith say that the prophet
muhammad sallam is saying that the sun
is going
somewhere or to an appointed destination
in the first place
now i want you guys to to understand in
the arabic language there's two things
something called
zaman and mccann that basically
when you're referring to destinations
there are two types of destination
time-bound ones and place-bound
ones as we'll come to know with this
particular hadith and the area in which
links with this particularity which the
prophet saw mentioned itself
the son we know from tafsir
is going towards the day of judgment
and this is the tafseer of chapter 36
number 38 where it says
that the sun is running to a destination
what destination is it is a time-bound
destination or is it a place-bound
destination
so the exegetes of islam the medieval
exegetes are talking about the end of
day so this is
eschatological in nature it's not
talking about a particular place where
in which this is going
uh whether this those who espouse the
scientific miracles narrative
it's the solar apex and those who want
to talk about the
uh you know the the scientific errors
narrative
are going to say it's beneath the earth
both of which are not indicated
by the primary text and what's the
evidence of this the evidence of this is
the exact phraseology the exact
terminology
of the of the hab of going is mentioned
in the quran where is it mentioned it's
mentioned in chapter 37
and verse number 99 well well where the
allah
i am going to allah and he will guide me
the same
exact phraseology there
i is going now what does this mean does
that mean that
somehow abraham is doing an israel
maharaja you know of his own no it
doesn't mean that it means
as qatar says that this is in many ways
a figurative
kind of going or if you don't want to
say it's a figurative kind of going
uh or something which is metaphoric then
you could say he is going with his
as pattada says who's part of the self
of the predecessors
he says this means that ibrahim is going
with his hammel
with his knee with his kalb with his
knee meaning with his intentions with
his khal meaning with his heart meaning
this the hab or this going it's not
talking about
a place bound going now bear that in
mind because there's another hadith
which is
extremely important maybe ironically but
definitely interestingly
narrated also by abu dhabi i'll tell you
why this is important
he says that the prophet muhammed
heavens and the seventh
earth in comparison to the kursi is
nothing but
a ring thrown in the desert and
certainly the hugeness of the hajj over
the course is like the desert over that
ring allahu akbar
allah the magnitude
of the hulk of the creation of allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala
look at that that the entire seven
heavens
is like a ring thrown in the desert
compared to the kursi now the kursi is
roughly translated as the footstool of
allah subhanahu wa ta'ala but it's
something which is not
okay they cannot be imagined and then
that compared to the arsh which is the
throne
and also the sealing of creation is is
is insignificant as well
now why am i mentioning this because the
question is
is there something that the sun does or
could there be on the
islamic cosmology something that the sun
does or somewhere
where the insignificant sun which is
placed
in the dunya in the worldly heaven how
do we know it's in the worldly heaven
because allah says
anywhere with the celestial objects in
chapter 67 verse number four
that is dunya so one of the seven
heavens
and then you have the kursi which is
like a ring compared to that
the movement of the sun in in this
context of the grand
scheme the cosmological grand scheme of
things
is completely insignificant
does it mean to say that and this is
another question does it mean to say
that if it's going under the arsh
is the assumption the false assumption
that
it wasn't underdarsh in the first place
or the throne
it must have been underdarsh because
according to this hadith i've just
mentioned
and other things in the quran as well
other ayat isharat that
the throne is the ceiling of creation so
there's nothing that can be
contained within the creation that would
not be in any way under the arch in the
first
place from the quranic cosmological
perspective
thus the sun was always underneath
us in as much the same way as ibrahim
was always on the earth
when he said innit
and so it's not insignificant to say
that i'm going somewhere or that someone
is going somewhere
or to some time when in fact they are
staying
in the same course that they are on a
physical
trajectory level so this question of
going somewhere that the hab the going
of the sun is one that has been confused
by the compounded ignorance of those who
fail to look
at the entire corpus of the quran and
sunnah
especially in the phraseological usage
of the key terms
that we have just mentioned also to add
it's very important we said we started
this segment off by talking about
that there are two kinds of zeman and
mccann or place and time
okay in the arabic language and both of
them have for all intents and purposes
exactly the same
grammatical and usually the same
phraseological and
semantical structures now here
we said that the the hab
of the sun or the going of the sun is
not in reference to
the actual going the physical going but
in fact it's about it's a time
bound
not from a can restriction and what is
the evidence of this from the sunnah
the evidence of this from the sunnah is
that the prophet muhammad
he ended the hadith with the vikra
or the mentioning of washington
and the sun runs to an er a determined
uh a determined to a a
a place slash time determined it can be
either and we said here
that almost all the exegetes agree that
it's an eschatological referencing
meaning
it's talking about the end times and the
day
of judgment so this shows that when he
was referring to abu dhabi about
the hell of the sun it was for
eschatological reasons
rather than cosmological reasons
and now this is where probably the
biggest issue that people have with this
hadith lies
which is in the understanding that is it
why did the prophet muhammad mention
this at sunset time
and they say this is probably the
biggest indication of geocentricity
or geocentrism and the answer to this is
actually ironically
that this is probably if you want to use
anything if you want to mention
cosmology in this uh this this sense
would would validate the heliocentric
model how is that possible
it could validate the heliocentric what
i was saying this is hadith is
heliocentric but that's not my claim
just to be clear
just as i would say it's not right to
say it's talking about geocentrism
but why is that you see the prophet
salallahu sallam he mentioned this
hadith at the time of sunset
now if the assumption is since he
mentioned it in the time of sunset
that has to do with the movement of the
sun because
the sujud he says that the sun set
and then it asks for permission to rise
again from allah goes to the throne and
asked permission to rise again now if
you think about it there is a verse in
the quran
which is very powerful and telling it is
in chapter 22 verse number 18 what allah
says
and then the verse continues do you not
see
that to allah prostrate all things
in the heavens and in on the earth
and the shams the sun and the moon
wait a minute wait a minute why is it
significant
because if there is an inextricable link
that is to be made between the sujud
the prostrate the prostrating to
under the sun so the prostrating of the
sun
and the sunset
if there's an inextricable link the
quran says
yes and it's mentioned in
which means it's a continuous present
tense wait a minute
what does this mean it means to say that
the sun
is always prostrating to allah subhanahu
wa tala it's not doing it
in the past it's not sajid allah and
it's not doing it in the future or it's
going to do it in the future say yes
yes because these would be the things
you'd have to put proof
in the prefix of the word is saying yes
which means it's happening continuously
in the present
wait a minute if this means what it says
that it would say it would suggest
that so long as the sun is prostrating
it's also setting and obviously
if we now want to introduce the flat
earth stationary earth cosmology
which those detractors of islam
are insisting on their websites and on
their
anti-islamic apologetics that
the quran depicts a flat earth
stationary earth cosmology with the
sun going around it wait a minute but on
such cosmology
the sun would not be setting at all
times
wait a minute wait a minute yes because
if it was a flat earth stationary earth
cosmology
the sun would go underneath the earth
and there would be
time periods where in which it's not
setting on
anybody at all there would be no such
thing
as a constant rube or
a constant sunset so this in fact
ironically
it actually takes away from the
cosmology that they are trying to build
in their scientific era narrative and in
fact
on the heliocentric model this is
definitely the case
where in which the earth rotates around
its own axis
it's always setting it's always setting
on someone
the sun is always setting on someone why
because the earth is continually
spinning around its own axis
thus if or prostration
is connected with rob or
setting of the sun then it must always
have
be setting it must always be setting and
this would in fact
negate the flat earth stationary flat
stationary earth
geocentric cosmology which these
anti-muslims are trying
to project now they could say well this
is a contradiction between the hadith
and the quran
and if this was the case the muhaddithin
would have rejected it and it would be
seen as i loved the hadith
the hidden defect of the hadith just
like hadith torba for example was
rejected on similar grounds as
muslim so if it was a contradiction it
would have been rejected because of meta
criticism
or the criticism of the content of the
hadith but the
aramaic did not see it as that so it's
not something it's
as we have just done now uh we have
reconciled it with the
quran we have reconciled it with
heliocentric models i don't think
there's an issue here
and so with all of this having said
being said
we can conclude quite safely that
this hadith is not talking about the sun
going under the throne and it wasn't
under the throne before that
or it's not talking about the sun going
under the earth because if it was if
it's a flat stationary earth it would
not be setting and we know from the
quran it is
the sun is constantly prostrating and if
it's constantly prostrating it
must mean it's constantly setting and
therefore
the boomerang the intellectual boomerang
has hit them once again
it's always ironic that when those
individuals they try and attack islam
the very evidences they use are usually
used against them
inshallah today what we're going to be
talking about is something which relates
to the subject
of quran and embryology and a particular
contention which people have
which is that the quran allegedly says
according to these detractors
that i've seen their material on
anti-islamic websites
that the quran that the human being is
made up from
a congealed clots of blood and we know
from embryological
study that that is not the case and they
say
the word alaka which is the operative
word
the important word it doesn't mean to
cling
or to be attached to something which is
what many muslims of today
say which they say is a superimposition
of modern scientific jargon
into the vocabulary of the quran
so let's deal with these two contentions
one by one
the first thing i'm going to be dealing
with in charlotte is the second thing
i've just mentioned
which is the fact that this word
cannot mean something which clings or
something which is attached to something
else
and that in the vast commentarial
tradition
and the vast exegetical tradition for a
thousand four hundred years
this meaning was unknown to medieval
scholars
and this meaning was not used in this
way
to indicate attachment or connection the
truth of the matter is that is false
that in fact medieval scholars from the
very early days
of islam were mentioning in their
treatises
in their dictionaries and in their
exegetical
and commentarial works that in fact
alaka
does mean to be attached to or connected
to so i'll give you one or two examples
ibn jazi
he says this and he was a sixth century
scholar al-azfahani who
has a dictionary talking about the
mufradat
of the quran or the singular words of
the quran
he also mentions that one of the
meanings of the word
is something to be attached to to its
companion so something to be attached to
something else
to be connected to it so this is a
species
and uninformed claim quite frankly
i am quite surprised i'll be honest that
these individuals who are making these
claims didn't do
themselves the academic justice of
looking at these medieval
books or they were foolish enough to to
think
that we were not going to do that indeed
these meanings are there they are
codified they are written
and they exist now the second contention
is they say
well we okay let's give it to you it
could mean to be attached
to or connected to something which will
go in line with
modern embryonic understanding of the
embryo being attached to the uterine
wall
and obviously through umbilical cold and
others other things
you know taking from the nutrients of
the host in this case the mother
they say fine it's in connection with
this but this other
thing or meaning is completely
unscientific
which is the meaning of a congealed
blood because they say it's not blood at
all
it's not blood the composition the
chemical composition of the fetus
is not a bloody one it's not one that is
composed
primarily of blood and you see this is
where
their argument is going to fall flat
on its face because this again
is a weakness of the understanding of
the arabic language
and in fact a weakness of the
understanding of the sunnah of the
prophet muhammad
because the prophet muhammed himself
said he said in the hadith
that two things have become allowed for
us
or two things which are may it or
dead and two things and he referred to
the word
daman two blunts the word them in arabic
means blood
he says two damn two dems have become
allowed for us and the two dems in
particular
is the liver el cabid and the spleen
now we know that the kevin the liver
is not something which is composed
primarily chemically from blood
but why is it the case that the prophet
muhammed
although some of the the festivals of
the hadith executes of the hadith they
say this hadith
which goes back to the sahabi if that is
the case which i don't believe it is
from reading the hadith tradition and i
believe it's going back to the prophet
but even if it is makuf it's still what
you call it
it's still something to be uh you can
use it as a way in which the language
was used
either way it doesn't matter the blood
was being in reference in this hadith
it was being in reference to something
which is not chemically composed of
blood
but it looks ready reddish so therefore
we can conclude that something which is
not
blood in chemical composition can yet be
referred to as blood
if it has the aesthetic appearance of
that
and we know that the embryo has the
aesthetic appearance
of something which is congealed and
bloody
even though the chemical composition may
not be so
someone may say that the word alakar
shouldn't be treated the same way the
word dem because dem means blood
and it was being used to refer to
something which isn't chemically blood
but it itself is chemically blood but
this would not be applicable to the word
alaka we would say no this is not the
case
because the hadith itself talks about
two dead things and two blood things
and the two dead things in questions
were not actually dead so this shows
that the word can be used in the arabic
language to reference
aesthetics so in other words something
might not be the thing
but you're using it to indicate the
aesthetic similarity of the thing
thus this is a species claim and a
foolish one
the real question is why use the word
when the arabs had another word for the
word fetus
which actually the quran uses which is
the word janine
which means fetus why did the quran
specify the word this is something
because subhanallah is true
it's true that the fact that the
embryo clings onto is attached to the
uterine wall so it has this meaning
which the word janine
does not have and in fact the quran
could have said
a congealed clot of blood but the quran
did not use this phraseology
and indeed it used a phraseology which
is more specific
and more in line with our understanding
of embryology
and though this fits in with the
multi-layered approach
that we believe in here in sapiens
institute which is the idea that the
quran speaks to people
in a timeless way people of all times
and all places including us in the 21st
century
and that is the reason why allah used
this very specific word
was
today we're going to be talking
inshaallah about this issue
of the earth being created or supposedly
created before
the heaven as per the quran this is the
claim that
many of these detractors make and it's
littered all over their
websites so what is the claim the claim
is
that the quran says that the earth was
created before the heaven
and this is wholly unscientific
something which is primitive and
something which is more indicative of a
seventh century type of
um authorship rather than the create
creator of the heavens and the earth
so what are the verses that are being
referenced with this kind of shubha
there are two main verses actually two
only verses in the quran
that they use to to make this
this claim the first is in chapter two
verse twenty nine so it'll be
says
that he is the one who created um all
that is in the earth and then he turned
to the heaven
and made them as seven heavens and in
chapter number
41 verse number 12
that he is the one who ordained them as
seven heavens in two days
and he gave to each of those heavens its
affair
or their command so they say look it's
clear here
that in the first verse that we've
mentioned the creation of the earth is
mentioned and then after that
the creation of the heaven is mentioned
and therefore
that shows a clear chronology and that
is not
a foolish interpretation of the quran
because aslan as the default position
the word thumma
which is critical here is usually used
as the arabic grammarians say or for
subsequent um chronology so if something
is saying
i did this for this storm or this
they're saying that they did this and
then they did this afterwards and then
they did after
they did this afterwards but the reality
of the situation is that you find in the
quran itself
examples where thorma is used
conjunctively
and not as or not used chronologically
so for example if you look at chapter
number 6 verse 154
yes and then we gave moses the book uh
completed
and from the one who perfected all
things and
as a detail for everything so soma here
even at tabari mentions in his tafsir
does not mean
uh conjunct it does not mean sorry
chronologically subsequent it means here
conjunctive so it works like well in
other words it doesn't mean
something is happening after something
else thus we know now as a principle of
language that thomas can actually mean
something conjunctive
and doesn't always have to mean
something which is successive
in the chronological way but then what
do we make of those two verses that
we began this video with well
the the mufassirin of the exeges of
islam
are in disagreement so for example
you'll find patada
one of the early commentators of the
quran one of the most
foremost commentators of the quran in
fact part of the salaf is a tabba
himself he believed that the heaven was
created before the earth
and thus he doesn't believe the word
thunder indicates
a transition or a subsequent uh movement
of chronology likewise many commentators
medieval commentators believe the same
thing
even hayan being one of them
being another and obviously these
individuals all lived in the medieval
period
where you'll find that al qaeda sorry
takes view and he says this is the
correct view insha allah meaning
he believes that there was um
a a there was no con there was no um
chronology indicated in these verses
and that's why um actually many people
like fakhruddin al-razi
and his history does not believe also
that that is talking about
something in something else so here you
have two valid ways of looking at these
verses
one of them is scientific and the other
one is unscientific
now for all intents and purposes if
we're looking at this
just purely exegetically both of those
are fine
interpretations and both of them uh both
of those interpretations
are supported by the language one can
have an unscientific understanding and
believe that the heaven
the earth was created before the heaven
and one can have
the idea that the earth was create the
heaven was created before
the earth both of those things are
supported in fact
when qatar was making his argument he
says in chapter 79 verse 30
that allah he uh delek after that he
smoothed over the earth he used this as
a kind of evidence to suggest that the
the heaven was already there and if we
really analyze
these two verses that we talked about
one in bakara and one in surat
al-fusilat
it doesn't actually say allah created
the heavens after he created the earth
and this is critical here
it's extremely important he says
so he proportioned them as seven heavens
and a lot of people don't realize that
assamet or the heaven
is ashmelomina is actually more
comprehensive
than the seven heavens why is that
because as-sama
includes everything that is above which
could include the seven heavens and
all those things which are above the
seven heaven and in islamic
cosmology we have the kursi and arsh
which are above the seven heavens but
are included in the sama
so thus the sama because in
the arabic language it means everything
that is above includes the seven heavens
and includes more than the seven heavens
thus if the sama was already created and
allah
proportioned them as seven heavens it
doesn't mean he created them
after the event of creating the earth it
just means that the
the finalization process when it came to
proportion had taken place
after the earth had already been created
but that's something completely
metaphysical to us
because according to the islamic
discourse we live in dunya the first of
those seven heavens
because the quran says you know we
created in sort of
we made the we we put basically uh
firmaments or luminaries in the uh
in the in the first heaven
we have created this dunya the first of
those heavens
with masahabi which are luminaries and
we have made in pelting things for the
shelting
thus one can legitimately
exegetically have an unscientific
approach and one can have a completely
scientific approach if you wanted to put
it this way because it's not just big
bang cosmology it's almost all the
theories out there
would suggest the universe or the fabric
of space was created before the earth
so one can have that interpretation and
one can have the other interpretation
it's unscientific but it's unfair
it's really unfair to say that the only
interpretation
which exists of these verses is an
unscientific one in fact
that is a historical claim above all
things
because we know that there are people
from the salaf all the way through the
medieval times
believed that the the heaven was created
first the universe was
called the universe you can call it the
universe the heaven was created before
the
earth and in fact they use they use
the quran itself as an indication of
that
so these are two valid interpretations
one side point
some people use a hadith which is
mentioned in sahih muslim
and in that hadith it says that the
earth was created on sunday
and then this thing was created on
monday uh yom nain and then this thing
was created on
wednesday which sounds like a genesis
kind of narrative although this
hadith isn't muslim almost all the
scholars
himself says this hadith is which means
it has
hidden defects and this hadith is weak
it's rejected and there are some hadiths
a few of them is muslim and a few of
them in
which have been spoken about in those
terms so that hadith now can't be used
as
an additional kind of evidence for those
individuals who want to
push the scientific error narrative
because quite frankly it's a weak hadith
according to
the major scholars of islam in summary
in summary we can say
there are interpretations of
naturalistic verses which are
unscientific
and this is probably one of the best
cases to look at that however
one can't just say that and stop there
is
also or there are also those scholars
and exegetes who interpreted the same
evidence
in a scientific way or in ways which
correlate with 21st century science
thus the exege should be left to their
own devices
and from an islamic perspective this is
not a kufri thing
someone cannot be a disbeliever for
believing either of those things the two
valid interpretations
but this is a species claim if the claim
is
the correct interpretation is one was
created before the other
because we know the language is meaning
it's inclusive enough to include both
possibilities
wassalamualaikum warahmatullahi
so let's take a look at what they say
they look at chapter 67 verse 5.
where it says that we have thereby
adorned
the dunya the worldly heaven with
luminaries and we have made them pelting
things for the devils
and they say this means or how could
this be the case they question they say
how could it be
that you have these luminaries in the
sky
that are pelting devils this is very
unscientific they say
and moreover they would go and say that
it's probably the case
that muhammad sallallahu alaihi he
confused between the meteors
which are very small in size and
composition and
stars because when they may have seen
shooting stars
they just they thought that that were
that they were actual stars
and therefore they argue this is
showing you the unscientific nature of
the authorship of the quran this is
these are really the two arguments that
are being made
and let's be honest the first argument
is a foolish argument
because science is predicated on
methodological naturalism so what
they're doing is a category mistake
fallacy
they're using something which is
predicated on
methodological naturalism to detect to
attempt to detect
that which is clearly in the realms of
the metaphysical
which is in this case a devil the devil
the jinn the angels the
heaven hell all of those things are seen
as
metaphysical things things which are not
meant to be detected or tappable by the
scientific enterprise by the five
senses and thus the first part of their
argument is actually uh shame on them
really for
for having this limited knowledge on
this on this kind of thing and
entering an arena of polemics with this
limited knowledge
and embarrassing themselves and
everybody else but even
more embarrassing is the fact that they
are making this
supplementary argument now that well the
prophet muhammad
must have been confusing between the
meteors
and uh the the the the celestial uh
spheres
um the uh the the moon the sun
the stars all those things all of them
are in one category for the prophet
and therefore he couldn't distinguish
between a small rock-sized meteor
and uh you know a huge uh
star and obviously this is a foolish
understanding
actually it's a foolish understanding of
the verse itself because chapter 65
verse five
according to him kathir he says in
kathie who's a medieval scholar
and exergy of the quran one of the most
prolific actually he says it's not the
misbah itself it's not the star itself
and yes he believes it is asa
is not synonymous with the word stars
because
means luminaries things which illuminate
in the sky which could be anything
anything which illuminates from the
anthropocentric perspective
anything from our humanly perspective
which illuminates in the sky could be a
misbah
because must be literally a lamp but
even cathedral takes the view it is the
najuma is the stars and he says
he says actually this not the star
itself which is pelting the devil
he says it's not the star itself but the
soul of flame which comes from this
from the star and you'll say well this
is a long shot how could he say that and
why would he say that
well actually he was doing qur'an quran
because he was executing the quran with
the quran because we look at chapter 38
verse number 10
it says
it says except for the one which follows
in course and therefore
it follows it shihab
so here this flame on
uh is correlated with what is mentioned
in chapter 38 of the quran
while it says
we have therefore adorned the heavens
with the zena with the adornment of
al-qaeda
kawakib means once again it could mean
stars
so here if you correlate the two verses
it would suggest to
uh to us that actually it's not the star
itself but it's the shihab of the star
and you say okay well i'm not convinced
yet maybe that is the case but i'm not
convinced okay if you're not convinced
no problem because there's another
hadith
this one's in bukhari where the prophet
himself he said
he says it could be the case when he was
talking to his companion
that that devil is being pelted by
shihab
once again shahab means a solar flame so
even if you look at the sunnah the
hadith
literature once again we realize that
it's not
the uh the star itself which is pelting
the devil
but in fact it is the soul of flame
which is being emitted from the star
which is pelting the devil and once
again you'll never be able to see this
on a metaphysical perspective but once
again it shows the shallow research
and the superficial reading cursory
reading newspaper reading
of those individuals to the islamic
literature so this is an education for
them and insha'allah will be benefit
for everybody else
today we're going to be talking about
the the matter of six days
and what do we mean what does the quran
mean when it says six
days the universe was created all the
heavens and the earth were created in
six days
does this mean six 24 hour days and if
so how is it possible
how can it be conceivable that the
universe
which we know has been around for 13.9
billion years
or at least that's what science tells us
can in any way
have been created in six days
well to answer this question really what
we have to look at is what the quran
actually says
and what the quran what the arabic words
actually mean
to summarize this point really the word
yom
which the plural of is ayam means any
time period
and what is the evidence of that the
evidence of that is the fact that
individuals like alice fohani had
written in their mahajim
their dictionaries long time ago that
the word yom is any period of time
and that is why the quran has this usage
of the term
in referencing different periods of time
so you'll find
in for example surah sajdah chapter 32
of the quran
in verse number 10 allah says
that he that god controls the affair
from
the heavens to the earth and then it
ascends back
uh
that was a thousand years from how you
count or from your reckoning
so clearly here the word yom is used in
reference to a thousand
years and likewise in chapter 70 verse
five in surah
marriage it talks about the day of
judgment it says
in a day which its length is 50
000 years so how could it be that you
have one day that's one thousand years
and another day which is fifty thousand
years well even at best
uh the cousin of the prophet muhammed
and the most
qualified person after the prophet
muhammad to ever deal with exegesis
he actually replies to this question by
saying these are two different days
and this is mentioned in sahih bukhari
the most authentic book after the quran
he says
these are two completely different days
and so therefore you know a day in
summary could be
any period of time when allah talks
about the creations of the heavens and
the earth in six
days it could mean uh six
24-hour days that's a possible meaning
but that's not the only meaning
it could mean any period of six days
so really or six periods of time
therefore this contention that well the
universe is 13.9 billion years
and how could the quran say in six days
is a
fundamentally flawed uh question to
begin with because
the sixth period of time could mean any
period of time or i think really what's
happening here is
that there has been a conflation there
has been a superimposition
of the genesis narrative as per
um evangelical kind of fundamentalists
if you want to call it that
or literalist readings of of genesis
chapter
one chapter two chapter five as well
looking at all those um
you know lineage models that are
mentioned in genesis chapter five in
particular
adding them all up and then coming to um
you know conclusion that is six thousand
years
and we don't have the equivalent of
genesis chapter 5 in the quran
we don't have the equivalent of genesis
chapter 5 in the hadith
so this is not our really our contention
because quite frankly it's not something
we have to deal with
so in some in some you know
the day could mean any period of time
and so it's not in conflict with
the fact that the universe could have
been 14 billion years
or it could be more than that it could
be less than that and really we don't
know how long the universe
has been around for obviously big bang
cosmology would
would bring us to the conclusion that's
been 13.9 billion years but
science is far from incorrigible and far
from producing of eternal truths
so we remain if you like happy to accept
whatever science says and there's no
conflict
at all between believing in a model of
the universe that is 13.9 billion years
and believing the quran that's fine but
we don't need to be dogmatic
on what it is that the quran says
or what it means by six periods nor do
we need to be dogmatic at all
about the universe being 13.9 billion
years
and i hope that answers the question
wassalamualaikum
today i'm going to be speaking about
something which is actually littered all
over the kind of
anti-islamic websites a species argument
really
an argument saying that the you know the
quran and hadith or islam
in this primary text indicates that the
earth is flat
let's take a look at the quran and the
commentaries of the early people because
i think that's a very important place to
start
so if you look at the entirety of the
quran from fatiha until nest you'll find
that really the earth is being referred
to in different ways
you know in surat al-baqarah for example
the very first
chapter after surah had the second
chapter in the quran
allah says
you know he is the one who has made for
you the earth
as a spread if you like and he sent down
from the sky
water and if you look at the 88th
chapter of the quran
allah subhanahu wa he asks some
cool questions and one of them one of
those rhetorical questions is
have you not seen the earth and how it's
how allah has made it smoothed it over
for this reason some people actually in
the early times as well as
those individuals who are indicating
that this is the only interpretation
islam
are saying that well look the quran is
indicating that the earth is flat
they'll even look at chapter number
chapter number 78 of the quran where in
the beginning of the surah allah says
have we not made the earth as a bed
and this is another argument our bed is
flat and therefore the earth is
indicated as flat
this is not the case because as early
commentators have indicated
people like ibn hasem who is a you know
fourth century fifth century scholar
someone who was not influenced and could
not have been actually influenced by
modern scientific discussions he says in
his book el fisal
he mentions that the quran indicates
that the earth is round and his argument
is in chapter 39 verse 5
allah says
god says he rolls the day into the night
and he rolls the night
into the day and he has made subservient
for you then
the the champs the sun and the moon the
camera
and every single one of those are
running in an orbit
to a time appointed to a place appointed
so in other words chapter 39 verse 5 he
says
that taking place
could not have been uh or could not be
at a queer that takes place
on a flat surface he says that the
taquer comes from the arab word korra
which me
which indicates that by necessity this
would mean
that the night is rolling into or onto a
spherical kind of surface and
likewise the day and therefore the earth
is round according to the quran so how
does he explain and other scholars
explain
those other verses which we started this
this discussion with which indicate
that the earth is uh you know it's been
it's been stretched out
mood that or it's been uh you know
spread out and so on and so forth
he says well if you look on a you know
for example
if you look at a plane of the earth the
earth word in
in the first place actually means the
ground below so
as we're looking at the ground below
we're seeing that it's been smoothed
over
in opposition to for example you know
the creators of the moon
so if you look at the moon and look at
the kind of the
the the the ground on the moon the
craters on the moon is very bumpy
whereas the earth uh the you know
the surface of the earth is very smooth
and that's how they're able to harmonize
between the two
kinds of verses likewise ibn tamiya and
his kitab
al-arsh which is part of majmar till
fatawa
a literalist in his own right or
apparentist wherever
you want to put it someone who looks at
the quran and doesn't even believe in
metaphor in the quran this is one of the
only
people in the history of islam who's
actually said we don't i don't even
believe in
such a thing as a metaphor in the quran
he says that the earth
is round that he he in fact even quotes
an ichman
he he quotes a consensus among the
scholars on this on this point
now this view he says in tamiya goes all
the way back to the early generation
to a person who has a chain of narration
called ibn munedda
so ibn munada is someone who comes in
the fourth century or the third century
and who says that the earth is round
and he is one of the students of ahmed
ibn hambal another person who
um he wasn't going to metaphorize verses
of the quran
especially those cosmological ones which
could be referring to certain
phenomena therefore i think in some if
we were to be fair to the tradition
i think the most that can be said in
terms of making an argument against the
quran is that the quran can be
interpreted
as saying the earth is flat but you
can't say that that is the only valid
interpretation
that's an impossible thing to say in
fact it's historical because
it's something which has been disproven
by the very fact
that the most apparentist and literalist
scholars of the early times
people like ibn hasem who is avayari he
was someone who is a literalist
he you know it does not believe yes
analogy or
someone like him in tamiya who does not
believe in majes or
metaphorization of the quran people like
that
and ahmed ibrahim and his ashab people
like even monada they said the earth is
round
and they based their view on
their base their view on the quran and
the verses of it so
this species argument that's leveled
the quran or islam is exactly that it's
it's really a weak argument with very
little
explanatory or refutational power when
it comes to the
historical exegetical works of the
muslim scholars
and so for this reason we say this
is a null and void refutation which i
can't even believe quite frankly i can't
even
fathom how this has made the top
10 of the most if you like
popular interrogations against islam
in these weak websites against islam i
can't believe it that people actually
take these arguments
as carrying any kind of weight and they
continually use these arguments despite
the fact
that the evidences have been shown time
and time
again but these people are not ready and
listen
ready and willing to listen to this
evidence so we just have to put it out
there
feminist
the quran says whoever wants to can
believe and whoever wants to
can disbelieve wassalamualaikum
well i hope all of those videos that you
have just watched or indeed if you have
just even watched some of those videos
were able to challenge your thought
process
or satiate your curiosity we would like
your feedback
if you are someone who was suffering
from some kind of doubt
whether or not this series has helped
you so we will link
a poll where you can tell us
whether how satisfied and convinced you
have been
with the answers you have been given
this will give us a chance an
opportunity
to be able to introspect and to
self-reflect
and to improve our service positive
reinforcement is as good as negative
reinforcement and vice versa
so tell us what you think needs to be
changed
by emailing us on the email below
or indeed as i've mentioned by telling
us
by polling how convincing you have
thought these
answers to be the conclusion of all of
this
is the approach of trying to use
science to attack islam has really a
failed being a failed approach not least
because
science it assumes scientism the idea
that science is
omniscient if you like as one of its
presuppositions
scientism is something which is almost
rejected fully
by the philosophical community except
in evangelical corners of new atheist
propaganda and so
the interlocutor who believes in this
must really come forward and explain
himself
or herself as to why they believe in
scientism is true in the first place or
how can it be
demonstrably proven to be true
the truth of the matter is as we have
been showing throughout this series
the quran has an inbuilt flexibility and
facilitation
which allows people from the 7th century
all the way through to the 21st century
and beyond
to be able to make sense of the book
according to the cosmologies
and modern day scientific theories of
the day
in other words i don't have to as a
muslim
sacrifice my understanding of science in
order to be a practicing muslim i don't
have to
have some kind of cognitive dissonance
in seeing an observable reality in one
way
and approaching the text in another i
don't have to resort to
huge conspiracy theories relating to
this to the age of the universe
and the existence or lack thereof of
dinosaurs
or the coexistence of dinosaurs as human
beings or any of the kind of propaganda
that we're seeing with
new age uh literalists from the
christian
from our christian core religionists we
don't need to do any of that
we can and this is unique within the
islamic tradition
maintain an absolute
for the most part literal understanding
where the language is
clearly literal of the naturalistic
verses
and not be out of line with that which
we generally know
to be observed reality today in the 21st
century
i think this is something which can
easily be argued to be
unique to the islamic tradition and
something which once again
allows a rational person to be able to
make
life decisions about religion which
doesn't compromise
a rationality for spirituality or vice
versa
this removes cognitive dissonance from
the equation and allows someone to
become
fully actualized spiritually and
rationally
and this is why you could argue
one of the clear reasons this
multi-layered approach of the quran of
facilitation
why a proof you could say
of the quranic authorship from a divine
all knowing or wise god
was allah
you